at the end of time
[Music]
13 o'clock
hey everybody what's going on that's a
good intro it's Wednesday I I like how
it turned out if I did say so myself
high impact
spinning at you coming at you it's
coming at you yeah it's like oh [ __ ] man
it's going oh [ __ ] down man it's going
down I like it
today is Wednesday
this is the main show
and we gotta we got another UFO case
which well ufo-ish ufo-ish alien-ish you
know how I am with with these cases I
like them and I don't know this case so
it's the first time I'm hearing of it so
you know what I mean I gotta stay sober
if I get too drunk then I'd be like what
but that you know it is it's more what
is it it's more interesting it's more
interesting for me A lot of times when
I've never heard of the case because you
know if I already know the case then I'm
sitting here just waiting to get through
it you know what I mean you know it's
like watching a movie you've already
seen before you know it's like that
but uh now I can be kind of like part of
the audience and just listen go oh yeah
you know but I don't know this one I
don't know this one at all what's this
what's this about it's kind of like yeah
Tom Sykes says another skin walker Ranch
case but better yeah this one is kind of
like I feel like it's not as well known
as Skinwalker Ranch but it's kind of
like on a similar wavelength where yeah
there's alien and UFO activity but
there's oh so much more yeah where is
this Arizona Arizona to down the
Southwest where all the crazies [ __ ]
live yeah all the crazy desert people
because Skinwalker branches in Utah yeah
I think I think it was it okay yeah all
right so this should be good
should be good who's in who's in the
chat
um everybody okay yeah a couple people
said uh yeah sick intro uh Grandpa's
Hammer said whoa that intro is totally
dope thank you thank you yeah yeah I
think this is only the second time we've
used it right because I think the I
think we just uh started it in the Navy
yeah Jenny's bringing it man when she
first showed it to me after she made it
I was like oh yeah that's [ __ ] office
I said you knocked out of the parchment
don't change a [ __ ] thing and she got
a big smile on her face she's like yeah
yeah so do not change a [ __ ] thing
well I knew it was a good one yeah yeah
I didn't you know I said didn't even say
well you should maybe change this so
that you know sometimes that happens
right like I don't like the I don't
really like the logo I like the logo I
like everything
which is unusual because you usually
liked everything on you don't usually
like it's not me well I usually don't
like the very first
tries you know maybe you got it down
with science now because we've already
done logos
for for the show well and I've done like
a million different ones too like a
million different variations over the
years yeah so that one right well I mean
just of different ones like
experimenting with different things
let's talk about 13 o'clock logos yeah
that's what I meant yeah okay I've
experimented with different ones yeah
because I was actually throwing around
the idea of changing the logo like a
couple years ago and I did like a bunch
of variations but I didn't really love
any of them so we just like kind of kept
the one we had but you know what I mean
the new one you have now I [ __ ] think
it just knocks it out of the park that's
gonna be yeah like I said I like how it
came out well well and once we started
uh screen printing our own shirts yeah
um you know that kind of made me think
well I'm I want something that's really
like easy to scream it'll be easy to
screen print nothing real fine no little
Fine Lines because we weren't really
thinking about that when we did the
first logo so we I mean we weren't
really worried about it they have to be
pretty bold and kind of geometric and
easy to see they can't they can't be
overly complex or or the the screen
printing is too much there's too much
um
possibility for error when you're making
the screen and then after this even if
the screen gets made shooting it to make
it to make a
a picture the more complicated that is
the
the greater chances of [ __ ] that
shirt up it's easier when it's real
simple yeah but it has to be simple but
it has to catch your eye and has to look
cool and I I think you I think you
knocked out of the park and I'm hoping
that neon green die
will pop like that on a black shirt I
hope so too like without having without
having to do a white a white Under
yeah player I know
which
I could break down and get it get the
two color
the two color machine to hold the shirt
to do the two colors
but I have to have room to assemble it
so which I guess is some on shirt dad
have to assemble it in the living room
yeah
and what if I only wanted to make one
shirt or two it'd be kind of a piece
then it's a pain you gotta you know it
takes forever to set that up but I got
that foldable tail table down the garage
that I got to bring up we can work on
that and
maybe I'll look at a two or three color
or maybe they have four Colors Let's see
what the price differences are
you know yeah it's a rotational thing it
holds a shirt and it holds everything
everything has to be aligned and you got
it align oh yeah I mean it's just like
it's it's you know it's the same as it
used to be back in the old days with uh
paper Printing like any kind of CMYK
printing you always have to like line
everything up otherwise you'll get that
kind of like yeah it doesn't line up
right and it looks funny
yeah you know what I mean uh Tom Sykes
says supposedly John Edmonds uh is
friends with director Kevin Smith or
worked with him or something like that
oh I don't know
um I didn't realize but John Edmonds uh
the guy who whose story this is he
actually uh passed away as far as I know
last year sometime in 2022
so thank you very much Grand there's
Hamer what's up Graham in the lighthouse
lingo lookie with your handsome logo
bright as a lady's eyes
that's pretty funny uh and mango also
says R.I.P Jeff Beck holy crap he died
okay damn I would have thought he's dead
already he had been old really well you
know he was old when I was a kid
was he yeah I guess so in his 30s at
least
when I was in high school he was in his
30s or 40s yeah that's true yeah okay so
oh well what are you gonna do we're all
gonna die someday this is eventual
it's just it's the way of the force
mango said he was 78. 78 okay yeah yeah
so after the full life actually not as
old as I was as I thought he was
but yeah beautiful life
um let's see Richard Brown said it just
finished hopeful monsters which is one
of my books if you guys didn't know it's
short stories uh he says the best short
Story collection I've read in a long
time thank you very much that is so
awesome of you to say I am like always
really really stressed out when people
read my stuff
because I'm like super critical of my
own [ __ ]
but uh yeah he said you're a very
talented writer Jenny thank you very
much that's that means a lot that means
a lot I'm glad I'm glad you liked it do
we have a hopeful monsters commercial uh
yeah it's in it's in one of the strings
all right because I kind of feel like
I've written a couple novels too
um but usually I tell people to uh start
out with the short story I have two
short story collections the other one's
called Associated villainies because
over the past couple years Patron
patronage on um uh kind of slipped you
know we're missing like 300 bucks a
month
Jenny had to double down on the amount
of
shows that we do uh a week to try to
make up for it and add revenue and boy
they were ad Revenue money kind of comes
in you got to wait several months for it
to back up and
um
if we can get the patronage going right
Jenny can get back and write in a book
and we can kind of taper off on some of
the I mean I already have an idea for it
and I already started writing
um I have probably like I don't know I
don't know if I'd say a quarter but I
have like quite a bit of one I just
haven't had like time to what is it true
crime or is it it's a it's a horror
fiction but it's based on a true crime
case all right but it's like a
fictionalized supernatural kind of thing
but it's based on a real case
uh Zach says I forget the story name but
one of your shorts I'm always thinking
about is the one with the giant
man-eating Pearl yeah yeah yeah that was
I wrote that one for
I was actually writing it for because
every now and then like I'll try to
write a story for like a particular
um what do they call it like a a
compilation like where they were like
Hey we're doing a you know a book of
whatever kind of like zombie stories or
whatever so they have a call for you
know uh I can't remember words today I
don't know I call for admissions
admissions is that the word I'm looking
for submissions submissions there we go
I'm not having a stroke I promise I mean
maybe I hope I'm not but uh yeah so that
so that was um they were gonna do one of
like giant monsters and I thought to
myself it's like wouldn't it be funny if
like the monster wasn't like a big
lizard or a big bear or something like
that wouldn't it be funny if it was like
a giant oyster and so uh the story kind
of like
went from there but yeah I actually
really like that story too I don't know
if it's my favorite of all the ones I've
written but
um but I did I I did amuse myself with
that one
uh yeah so Tom Sykes says alien Grays
suck ass for hurting and killing
defenseless animals in both this case
and Skinwalker Ranch case I was thinking
that too I was like so I'm gonna tell
you guys like ahead of time that this
case in particular and I'm just gonna
say right out the gate I don't really
believe any of this stuff happened but
you know we'll we'll see but we'll we'll
get Tom's take on it but if it did
really happen
um these aliens can kiss my ass because
they are really [ __ ] up some animals
and I don't like it so you think this is
a tall tale
uh yeah I mean it's pretty outlandish
I'm gonna say that right now all right
well I'm gonna get I'm interested now
yeah it's the very outlandish story
because I kind of knew some stuff about
like I knew about
the UFO angler like the alien angle but
then like when I started researching and
I was like holy crap this is one of
those ones that just has like all the
things like going on you know what I
mean like just throwing everything but
the kitchen thinking I wish I could do
art Bell's voice I mean now would be the
time to do art Bell's voice but you know
skid Walker Ranch you know he
[ __ ] he was he was great he'd
get me in the mood to hear some [ __ ]
[ __ ]
half the time it was [ __ ] most of
the time it was [ __ ] but it was he
could make he could he could make any
[ __ ] story sound
exciting you know uh and some of the
[ __ ] I don't think was [ __ ] you know
like the Phoenix Lights when that
happened
somebody sent me a um an archive of all
of [ __ ] Art Bell shows or at least
all his best ones
and there's a segment of all the Phoenix
light stuff from the very first time he
mentioned it all throughout and then all
the guests and that that was real
interesting but it's a lot of material
you got to go through because it's the
whole show yeah you know I mean his
shows went on like three hours four
hours
ain't no one got time for that yeah well
no well there's commercials are in them
too no
no because somebody recorded them with
on a damn remember those old recorders
yeah yeah yeah that's how because that's
how a lot of them were recorded yeah
yeah I don't know where the originals
are I guess they all belong to
they're all up at [ __ ] uh our Bells
place after he died
so the ones that exist or
once the people recorded from home I
guess you hear the static and everything
yeah yeah
Tom syk says Uh there's an interview
with John Edmonds on the Project Camelot
YouTube channel uh yeah I saw part of
that where Carrie Cassidy is
interviewing him and in the background
you could see an alien gray head peeping
its head around the corner yeah I saw I
saw that clip and I
um fake looking to me it looks kind of
fake but I don't really know like it I
mean it was pretty well done if it was
fake but I'm just kind of like damn I
don't know you think of a CG or you
think it was a mask it looked like CG
you look like CG Sydney but what do I
know I wasn't there I'm just saying it
looked it looks kind of funny yeah it
was you know
it's a pretty it's a pretty famous uh
clip actually yeah okay so the gray is
[ __ ] looking into the window
well no he's in the house like he's kind
of like peeking around but it's I guess
it's like the corner of the wall because
there's like the back of the couch yeah
and then like it's like a little but you
couldn't really see him he wasn't like
super clear like hey what's up you know
what I mean it was just kind of like a
little bit of a it's funny yeah you know
what I mean
uh and then uh he also said Zach Baggins
and his crew visited Stardust Ranch and
seemed to think it's legit now didn't
they as far as I know
they thought that it was legit but they
didn't think it was extraterrestrials I
think they thought it was demons because
there's all kind of like other weird
[ __ ] going on with this that's
um some of it's like extraterrestrially
but some of it is kind of like
poltergeisty okay you know what I mean
that's kind of the way skin walker Ranch
that's what I'm saying this is kind of a
similar story I just feel like it's not
as well known as Skinwalker Ranch
because everybody's everybody knows
Skinwalker Ranch right we even did a
show about that yeah who bought that
thing didn't didn't uh wasn't it uh
o'lear yeah didn't somebody like kind of
famous bought it and then like yeah then
they tried to like launch some kind of
Space Program from there or some uh they
were working for the Air Force to try to
figure out UFOs there was some [ __ ] like
that yeah I remember how it happened I'm
not real familiar with the Skinwalker
Ranch anymore I
my [ __ ] detector kept going off yeah
we did a show about it but I don't I
mean I remember some of the details but
not like a lot of them and now it's
probably going to be all taken over
because I'm like it's doing the research
on this I'm like this sounds just like
skin marker range but it's kind of like
the same thing and I don't even remember
when that [ __ ] started
because this one supposedly started in
1996 okay are there any shout outs or
anything like that we have to do before
we start the show well I think we
shouted him out on one of the movie
reviews but I always like to do it on
the main show as well is our new Patron
who is Hugo oh Hugo Hugo is okay thank
you remember because
um yeah I shouted out before but like I
said I I usually like to do it why is
platoon sitting there that's been there
since we did the review I'll give you
that thing
I keep waiting for you to take it back
in your man cave and you just never take
it and I'm surprised he only just now
noticed it it's been it's been there for
like however many months it's been since
we've since we reviewed platoon which is
a long time ago but yeah he's just I
don't know it's been sitting there all
this time because you know I never
[ __ ]
straighten up in here it's like there's
just stuff everywhere I don't know what
to do
uh Tom Sykes says aliens and dimensional
beings are the same thing in my opinion
yeah I kind of feel like
I don't know what's going on at this
place I really don't
you know what I mean but like I said
we'll get into it
we'll get into it because
uh yeah so Zach is saying uh I'm
imagining I guess he's talking about I
think he's talking about the um
my man-eating Pearl story I'm imagining
that imagery from it as a movie that's
kind of how I imagined it well that's
how I imagine
um things that I'm writing them I
imagine it is though I'm watching a
movie and then I'm just like writing
down what's happening in the movie
that's so probably that's why
said I better be badass I remember
really I really like the characters too
okay so that's cool that's cool mango
badge we're talking about how Art Bell
was a broadcasting genius yeah he was
great man he was great he was the uh
the grandfather or great-grandfather of
shows like this really this you know he
was the one that [ __ ] kind of
invented this this type of deal where
you just talk about mysterious stuff
UFOs
you know he launched a lot of dudes
uh he had Zacharias sitching on there
all the time is that his name sitchin or
sich yeah and it's sitchin or snitching
or yeah we'd have him on chariots the
gods type stuff that's very Bond Anakin
isn't it oh well and I said Charities of
God's type stuff yeah okay and then uh
he had uh whole uh Graham Hancock that's
the first time I've ever heard of Graham
Hancock was on uh our bill and then all
this weird [ __ ] you know about the star
child the star child skull
I think we did a show about that yeah
like I don't know if we did an entire
show about it but that one had me amazed
because I couldn't see it
then finally uh I got a um
at the time I didn't have internet then
I got internet back and went and looked
at it this is back in the 90s
I couldn't believe it I was like oh man
that skulls really is as weird as they
say it is
it's an alien I didn't think that
I thought it was some kind of mutant
which is you know some kind of a I'm
pretty sure that's what it is yeah some
kind of birth defect
Zach also says uh Jenny I've been using
uh chat GPT to come up with story ideas
lately you should try it it's actually
super useful yeah I just heard about
that like not too long ago and I
probably will look into like I said I'm
really really hoping like one day that
I'll get to finish this [ __ ] novel
that I started because I think it'll be
really good but
you know I just I don't I don't have
time we've got to get the patron action
up yeah I mean if you actually back up
then we can get back again yeah because
I then I'd have yeah more time because
now I have to like you know do graphic
design work and put more videos out and
stuff like that too and I like I said
I'm gonna start doing I need to start
doing shorts too yeah because one
they're gonna YouTube is gonna start
monetizing them which they've been
talking about for a while and two
um you know you're more likely like
people are more likely to watch them
because they're only short and like you
can draw a lot more people to your
channel that way so what's weird is that
I try I did an experimental one and it's
harder than because you guys know how
[ __ ] verbose I am right so it's like
really really hard for me to cut down
things to like 60 seconds you know what
I mean I had to like I made like
experiment like an experimental one like
just to see how hard it was and I had to
edit like almost everything out that I
said you know what I mean because it was
like I I ended up like my initial
recording was like two hours two hours
two minutes yeah and 20 seconds so I had
to like take a minute and 20 seconds out
I uh uploaded a couple short videos they
came off my Instagram I just uploaded a
couple of them to my YouTube channel
and without even my permission it put it
in the shorts category well yeah that's
where it's gonna put it if it's if it's
a certain length well no it's not it's
not so much the length it's if it's um
vertical oh is that what it is yeah yeah
okay if it's vertical it's figure it out
I was like 10 it's 1080 by 1920. I
wanted to move it into my normal video
section and it wouldn't move it there it
moved it into into shorts
you know well yeah it's always going to
put it there yeah because that's what um
the format is that's the shorts format
like if it's vertical like a cell phone
video then it's gonna automatically it
doesn't really explained to me the nice
thing about it I just got to do it by
trial and error you know the nice thing
about it is that the YouTube studio app
yeah
um you can actually film them right in
there and you can edit them right on
your phone and there's like all kind of
really cool [ __ ] you can even do like
you can green screen yourself out and
like you can put yourself like in front
of someone else's video like a reaction
type video you can do all kind of stuff
just like right like natively like right
in your phone because I was just trying
to upload videos of my my progress my
physical progress and I guess I recorded
it upright like you said yeah like
vertical because it went over there and
I was like no I don't want it over there
I wanted them just regular videos but
whatever yeah I know well yeah it's
vertical so they're gonna put it in
there I got my guys
I I got air pretty much everything uh
for the uh for Bane Halloween costume
next year or this year end of this year
I had to send the damn armor vest back
they sent me a large instead of the
medium that I ordered I had to go out
and return that today but the rest of it
I've been working on working on a mask
getting that right arm brace look it
looks good
um ordered all the [ __ ] cycles that
I'm gonna do
I'm gonna get big I'm gonna try to pick
up another 10 pounds
and then I'm gonna [ __ ] reappear his
[ __ ] Bane you guys will see it it's
gonna look good it's gonna look good
that's a costume where you gotta [ __ ]
put on some weight to do it
it's gonna be nice I'm gonna be crazy
though when I start doing it we'll we'll
see what else is there we'll see well I
mean crazier I'm gonna be crazy today
I'm gonna do some Tran
but you guys will have fun with me [ __ ]
it I'll be doing shows during that uh
you know I'll fess up when I'm on cycle
so everybody will know when he starts
like yelling and crying and stuff crying
yeah I'm gonna make you watch The Ghost
and Mrs Muir again when you're on the
trend makes me a hoe man I start [ __ ]
getting all sentimental and [ __ ] oh just
yeah I like shitty light loves it
I get all sensitive and [ __ ]
I can't believe the dog died
but see like I said that's what I'm like
all the time when I was doing research
just to kind of pull it back to the like
link it back to the topic when I was
doing research into the Stardust Ranch
and it's like all these animals got
killed I was just like I don't I don't
even know if I can continue this this is
making it this is making me really
pleased well I've told you that I've
gotten to a thing now it's like I still
look I love horror movies I can watch
horror movies all day long where people
get killed I don't give a [ __ ] but man
the second you do something bad to like
a cat or a dog I'm just kind of I'm
watching it I'm like I don't even know
if I want to watch this anymore
you know I usually still do because I'm
like it's not real it's not real it's
not real but it's like you know it's
just fun I know that's [ __ ] up but
it's like I don't really I don't really
care if people get killed in a horror
movie I'm hardened to that
I've seen enough dead people where I'm
just like yeah that [ __ ] happens yeah
I'll be there soon but you know I mean
the little innocent animals and the you
know the babies and [ __ ] [ __ ] like oh
they didn't even know why you know what
I mean that's that's what yeah I think
that's what bothers right right that's
what bothered me too is that they don't
understand why yeah because it's like
right yeah
um
but that's the way it is in nature you
gotta [ __ ] buck up about that because
they're getting eaten alive in nature by
[ __ ] A lot of times you know they don't
really know why they just know they're
being eaten they're just ah you know
people chewing their legs off and [ __ ]
you know why they're still alive and
some it's sweetheart big old cats you
know what I mean got a hold of some
zebra and one of them's trying to choke
it out the other one says oh [ __ ] man
this leg oh hell yeah we're gonna eat it
I'm gonna start eating already well
Super Fresh well the boy while his
friend hasn't even [ __ ] finished
strangling them you know so
Nature's brutal like that it's just sad
you know that's how it is it is yeah I
know they all go to the Happy haunted
crowd afterwards anyway crossing the
Rainbow Bridge
yeah they go they go across the beef
Frost
[Laughter]
ah Richard Brown says uh the glass
ceiling was brilliant that's one of my
short stories by the way thank you very
much that was another one where the
prompt was write a story about a cursed
book and I didn't want to write about
like a spell book or like an evil dead
type of thing I said what if it was an
employee handbook that was like a cursed
book so that's where I got that idea
from that uh date uh Dave is here what's
up Dave uh like your five movie by year
review you cut out One flick bam a short
well I was kind of thinking of doing
what did you say what did he say no well
it's it's all right I know I know what
he's talking about all right but um well
what I was trying to do like the test
that I did I was kind of like okay I'm
gonna go like five movies that like five
horror movies that I'm looking forward
to like that are coming out this year
and even though I only talked about each
one for like a few seconds it's like it
was still too long so I had to like cut
out a bunch of stuff so I was like maybe
I should just do like one at a time like
that would probably be better because a
minute is really not that long mango
says YouTube shorts are a waste of time
just them trying to compete with another
platform oh they totally are they're
trying to complete with compete with uh
Tick Tock and uh you know Instagram uh
stories or Instagram reels rather but
I mean I don't know I just thought maybe
I would try some out because they do
um because they do get a lot more uh
viewership than longer videos do and
sometimes that'll bring people to your
[ __ ] [ __ ] that you know that might
not have found it otherwise but I don't
know like I said I'm gonna try and
experiment with them
and see what's going on Dave's telling
me I need to do some uh day uh Bane
reacts videos that would be funny yeah
thing is is uh I gotta get um
I got to get uh the Tom Hardy Bane voice
down I can do it I just have to
get used to doing it um I have to start
practicing it you got to get ready for
any role I can do I can do Hispanic Bane
like Danny Trejo especially when I get
mad I didn't forget Halloween the little
kids loved it
the kids loved it I was scared and I was
scaring the teenage girls and [ __ ]
coming
with [ __ ] uh with Hispanic Bane with
my luchadora mask on
and about candy
so I just got to get in in uh in
character for it but um yeah I gotta do
his I got to get his voice down I had to
watch the movie and practice it
um uh is it gen Pico or gen Pico I'm not
really sure uh They're laughing at my
description of this show Bigfoot type
creature and Men In Black in the mix too
because of course there was that's what
I'm saying there was like it wasn't just
aliens it was just all all the things
yeah I'm looking forward to it all the
things yeah you'll have a good time with
it okay uh Tom Sykes says I hate that
they killed his Rottweilers which are
the best dogs ever in my opinion yeah
like I said a lot of cruelty to animals
in this one uh dogs get killed horses
get killed but was this made up can you
prove these animals died
see that's what I mean I'm I'm gonna
come out right now and I think this
whole [ __ ] [ __ ] was made up but I
don't know I don't know we'll see
because it's easy for a guy to tell a
story yeah they killed my horse to kill
my dog but it's real hard for him to
kill his own dog to [ __ ]
you know what I mean to perpetrate a
hoax
well yeah I mean I'd like to see these
animals
did he take pictures of the dead bodies
no probably not okay we're gonna see
like I said there's not a huge amount
about this I will say that the dude John
Edmonds wrote a book
about it
um with somebody else and I was like
please tell me it's on Kindle unlimited
and I'll read it but no it's ten dollars
for the damn ebook and I was like I
really don't have ten dollars to like be
spending on this kind of stuff yeah so
so I had to like go because if it was
free or if it was like a couple of bucks
I would have read it but I was just kind
of like ten dollars that's a little
steep
um and so basically what I did was
there's not a lot of written stuff about
it there's a lot of podcasts about it
though so I went through and some of
them are quite long and quite involved
and I will say too that a lot of them
and I'll kind of point this out as we go
along but I kind of like I listened to
one and then I took notes on that one
and then I listened to like some other
ones and I made notes like where they
differed from one another because the
accounts like are slightly different
like in some of the details you know
which is gonna happen you know
hey Parker we might be going out to
mannequins this they're not mannequins
but uh uh yeah the mannequins this
Friday maybe oh you want to go Friday
yeah Friday or Saturday because Memento
is Friday but I don't know if you want
to go to that or because man they kept
going to that we're going to that over
and over again we did go to that one
well we went to that on New Year's Eve
that was fun yeah it's just for me it's
not as fun as as uh as mannequins
well and I'm gonna say that mannequins
is usually more fun on Fridays than it
is on Saturday yeah I'd rather go to
mannequins
well if you want to go to Martin well
I'm going to tell you right now I don't
have no money so I got it okay I got it
just telling you yeah Jenny's broke
people say super chat so don't be so
don't be like coming home and be like
hey want to give me half the bar tab I'm
like yeah I don't think I got I'm pretty
sure I'm pretty sure
it's not like I don't think I have to
pimp myself out this week
maybe you should start picking myself
out yeah you should start pimping
yourself out I already got an offer for
porn
yeah I mean maybe Queen Studios [ __ ]
saying yeah we'll take it and I was like
come back with your test and we'll put
you right to work how much do they don't
want to paint them oh
well I was going to say if they paid a
lot of money you might want to consider
it but yeah
but if they're just gonna pay like some
[ __ ] shitty out yeah yeah
I mean now Jenny's trying to pimp me out
now James trying to take me out of these
[ __ ] PornHub it would have to be a
lot of money and they're all married
women so you know [ __ ]
it would have to be a lot of money well
hey better you than me I'm not doing it
yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] well you know they
they they're looking for dudes like me
y'all that guys are in good shape
[ __ ] old enough age and [ __ ] look
scary and [ __ ]
yeah you're scared yeah Samantha I got a
good wardrobe for porn yeah
just shut up I got a good wardrobe got a
good wardrobe
shut my [ __ ] new Rocks new rock boots
[ __ ] and nothing else just yeah
just new rocks and underwear super tight
[ __ ] black silk underwear
with your pecker sticking out
the [ __ ] arm bracelets and [ __ ]
that's all you need
the biceps and [ __ ]
that'd be funny on a [ __ ] ton of Viagra
that'd be that's that'd be [ __ ]
hilarious yeah
ah okay we're in our 50s [ __ ] it
yeah that's kind of that's that's really
one of the only good things about
getting old is you don't really give it
you know stuff anywhere they're just
like whatever yeah we got a limited
amount of time anyway we were good
before there's no way I don't know yeah
Samantha said so where is this Ranch it
is in Arizona Buckeye Arizona is where
it is not too far I guess it's not too
far from Skinwalker Ranch how close I
don't know I was listening to a couple
other podcasts and they were talking
about skin walker Ranch which like I
said is in Utah but I kind of feel like
there's not a huge distance between
these two because I think they were
trying to imply that maybe there's some
kind of weird interdimensional Vortex or
something that like both of these
ranches happen to be in you know what I
mean it's like you know I don't mean to
be dismissive it's just this is a crazy
story you know it's just a crazy story
Samantha's taking me out what do you
thinking before Samantha there's no
context
just a cape
that [ __ ] David Parker he says he's
gonna be in there he's going tonight for
the [ __ ] karaoke yeah karaoke was
dead when Wednesday night in his carrier
yeah but it might have picked up that
was a long time ago yeah that was a long
time ago yeah
yeah me and murder heard it she says
well yeah me to talk about the same
payday that's that VA money that's when
the VA money shows up
that's right see I have like I have like
I have like two or three little tiny
paydays just like throughout the month
so it's like really kind of a pain in
the ass because I'm always like well gee
I have this bill due on this date but I
don't get money until like a few days
after that so you know what I mean it's
always kind of like a big pain like I'm
always shuffling money around you know I
got my VA money and I'm trying to pick
up side hustle money you know what I
mean [ __ ] porn is [ __ ] perfect for
that but them [ __ ] don't want to pay
that's why if you want to make a lot of
money you gotta do gay porn like no I
don't think
one of my [ __ ] steroid dealers that's
what he does you know he he
he does [ __ ] gay they do yeah okay
yeah they're gonna pay a lot more well
because like I said the straight porn um
you know men are like a dime a dozen
yeah it's always been like that right
and I was like dude man [ __ ] you you
said your girlfriend's cool with that
you know that you being being by like oh
I'm not bisexual I'm straight this is
dude come on what are you talking about
oh it's not like it's affection or
anything I'm not I'm not kissing anybody
and I'm just like my head was [ __ ]
real and I was like no dude that's gay
well like I said a lot of a lot of um a
lot of porn like they did gay for pain
yeah like a lot of those guys yeah well
he asked me if I wanted to work where
they make a lot of money he asked me if
I wanted to work with him because he's
got over more money than he's got only
fans too and I was like nah nah nah I'm
good he's like no I don't take it
personally man you know I just did you
know like no that's all right just a job
yeah that's the way he sees it but yeah
you know no I could do that Dave says
hey Jen I got your back on Friday I'll
buy you a couple Heathers my go-to who
is that Dave okay yeah oh I think I
would appreciate that that's really nice
I don't I don't mean to like cry for all
the time but I see right I'm sorry no
lately she's crying poor I'll let her
she's just trying to eat weasel out of
that no past couple months
it just started to pile up though and
the bills piled up
but it you know we get like I said we
get some more patrons we don't need it
it was only a couple hundred bucks as a
make or break you know what I'm talking
about we're at that point where we were
comfortable and then we fell down about
300 bucks a month and that was enough to
put some pain on us because it's not
just I mean the thing about it is it's
not just like paying for the house and
[ __ ] like that but it's like because I
have a bunch more bills than you have
because I went into debt a long time ago
yeah so I went into debt like I said
I've got like two credit cards that she
still needs to pay off
is it two what are you talking about I
have like eight credit cards that much
is it eight maybe it's seven
just that many of them I thought it was
only two or three no I have a whole
bunch of credit cards see she was hiding
credit cards from me how much a month is
how much I told you how much how much a
month is your minimum for all those
credit cards I don't know it's different
it's different every month yeah oh so it
wasn't all just like MasterCard and Visa
it was some other credit stuff like
store [ __ ] no no they're all mass card
reviews they're just like different
banks like I have two Bank of America
credit cards I have a couple Capital One
ones I didn't know that yeah she's
keeping [ __ ] from me no I'm not all
right put you out there [ __ ] working
get you out there on that [ __ ] street
corner
yeah no I'm not doing that Kevin yeah
man after you have the ship paid off
quick I'm just [ __ ]
I couldn't do that to her we got to get
that [ __ ] paid off though well no [ __ ]
but you know I can't do it now because I
couldn't put her on the [ __ ] I
couldn't I couldn't put her on the uh
now it's it's when I purchased this
house I couldn't put her on the
well yeah I told you not to what the
[ __ ] I was like it got declined I was
like my credit is horrified yeah but
it's like I mean it's not the worst it
could be but it's like it's like the
second tier up you know what I mean but
that's not just it's been like that for
a long time because you know what I mean
because I had some other things happen
that actually weren't well that had a
divorce yeah a lot of that happened my
divorce which was yeah many years ago
her divorce when she had when she got
divorced and she lost that house and
then she had to live off credit cards
for like about a year or so for a while
yeah but only about six months I think
until she until she reorganized Jenny
and I are wearing a cup weren't a couple
during that time we we were friends
hanging out almost every day but we
officially weren't a couple no
but um that's just how that [ __ ]
happened
yep and then life took over we never got
around to paying those off
well I paid him off
at one point but I had like fewer then
so it's like sometimes I kept losing
jobs and then I had to like you know run
them up again because the same problems
that you all have we got the same
problems you all have well and most
people unless you're a [ __ ]
billionaire right
um Tom Sykes is the old Rich owners of
this Ranch left all their expensive
belongings behind just like the previous
owners in the haunting of Florida case
yeah we'll get into that we gotta get to
this case they keep asking questions
about the case we need to start Richard
Brown said UFOs porn ghost this show has
something for everyone yeah right
and then Tom syk says John Edmond said
he stopped those aliens like dog [ __ ]
LOL yeah that's um that's another thing
that kind of makes me think that this is
maybe uh maybe a little bit Fantastical
this story right here uh is because
you know he's like an alien killing
badass which we'll get into that's just
a little teaser right there
uh so yeah
so John Edmonds uh and like I said uh as
far as I know he passed away last year I
think his wife might still be alive uh
his wife's name is Joyce
but you know so this is kind of his
story now from what I know I heard that
he was and like I said you know take all
of this with a grain of salt because a
lot of the stuff I tried to check into
stuff but there's not a huge amount of
info about this and it's like there's a
lot of podcasts about it they just kind
of like refer to each other you know
what I mean so you know I still want to
know how true a lot of this [ __ ] is I
try to like look into it so John Edmonds
was a psychiatric therapist I believe
and one of the things that he was really
into was I guess he was into like
rescuing and rehabbing like dogs and
horses and stuff so he had been wanting
like a ranch to keep said horses and
dogs on
so he had a bunch of horses and he had a
bunch of dogs I think most of them were
Rottweilers
so him and his wife Joyce I heard I
don't know what she was doing as a job
when they bought this place but I heard
that she was ex-fbi I don't know if
that's true or not
so they'd kind of been saving money for
a while you know so they could buy a
ranch a big piece of property
so they find this Ranch in Buckeye
Arizona which is 10 acres
now John immediately loves the place
he's just kind of like oh my God it's
like this big thing of land it's like
the house is really big and you know it
was kind of it was a little bit isolated
like you know the neighbors were kind of
far away and he liked that it was quiet
and everything
now evidently
Joyce didn't love the place
um when they first got there she thought
it was a little bit isolated she thought
it was a little bit creepy
um and she wasn't all that enthused but
I guess John loved it so much that she
was just kind of like okay fine so they
bought it uh so they actually moved into
the place in July of 1996.
so the first first weird thing that
happens and this is like the opening of
a haunting episode this is what I was
thinking because this would be this is
like a great opening to a story you know
I I was really intrigued by this
so John and Joyce
pull up in the driveway of the house and
they got the moving truck and all that
so they park by the front door
they go inside the house
and
all the former tenants or the former
owner or whoever left all of their [ __ ]
in the house like just laid out as
though they were gonna come back you
know what I mean all the furniture was
in there all the appliances were in
there and it all looked brand new
so John and Joyce are kind of like
um one why would anybody leave all their
[ __ ] here like this and two it's like
they knew that we were coming today we
were moving in so why didn't they move
all their [ __ ] out because now we have
to do it and that's like not cool you
know what I mean because it's like now
we have to take the moving truck back
tomorrow and now we don't have any room
for our [ __ ] right so they were kind of
like a little bit mad about it
so in one telling because there's two
different versions of this that I heard
so in one telling they call the realtor
up
um and the realtor says okay well you
guys go into town for a few hours and
I'll figure something out you know I'll
I'll get somebody to like come take care
of it or whatever
so they do that and then John and Joy's
come back like a few like several hours
afterward and they find that the house
is like completely cleaned out and
they're just like oh wow cool like it
got taken care of but wow that was quick
like how'd they get all that [ __ ] out of
the house like so fast
and so John goes through there and he's
like huh well okay and then though he
goes out to the backyard
and he noticed that all of the stuff all
the furniture I think that was in the
pool which was had been drained like it
was empty you know what I mean so it
wasn't like all wet and everything so
everything is just piled in the pool and
he's like what the actual [ __ ] so people
were gone yeah and then all their
Furniture was in a dried out pool yeah
well now initially like I said there's
two different versions I'll get into
that in a second
they got there all the [ __ ] was still
there as though someone still lived
there okay and then they called the
realtor and they're like what the [ __ ]
everything was supposed to be gone
because we're here with all our stuff
like the moving truck and he said okay
well I'll take care of it you guys leave
and then when they came back a few hours
later everything was cleaned out the
house but it was all in the pool now was
the pool covered was there a tarp there
oh I don't know
I didn't know if they ever try to store
something for safe keeping in the pool
but that's kind of crazy putting it down
in the pool why would you put it down in
the pool getting it in and out of there
be difficult unless they're making this
story we'll see that's what I but see I
really like let me get some ice whether
it was true or not I really like that so
I'm like that's a great opening for a
story yeah like that you come there and
it's like it would be weird and annoying
it's like man they didn't move their
[ __ ] out which like I said that's not
Sinister necessarily
um it's just kind of like oh what an
[ __ ] like they didn't get all this
stuff out but then like if you leave and
come back and then all the shit's in the
pool that is absolutely Sinister so like
I said I don't know if this really
happened or not but that's like a really
good opening to a story I like it so
just you know just from a horror writer
point of view I just really like it so
obviously he's really really mad
so he calls the realtor back and he's
like why is all this [ __ ] in the pool
now
um and you know who did you send out
here to do this
and the realtor apparently then said oh
well I didn't have anything to do with
it I've been trying to call the past
owners but apparently their phone has
been disconnected so I couldn't get hold
of them
so that's one account I've also heard
another account of this same incident
where the realtor told John that the
tenant or the former owner had actually
come to the house to get his stuff out
the previous day and that guy had found
all the stuff in the pool and thought
that John did it I've heard that version
of the story too so I don't know which
one of those is true
um yeah but yeah so there was some story
where like the the former owner like
came there and found all his [ __ ] in the
pool and it's like oh hey that new guy
that that came here like pushed all my
[ __ ] in the pool like what the [ __ ]
going on so those are like two different
versions I don't really know any more
details than that but those are like the
two uh versions that I've heard
so uh whichever version is true uh you
know John and Joyce were just kind of
like well this is like some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] but the Realtors basically like
well I wash my hands if it's your house
now so you just [ __ ] deal with it
whatever so I'm assuming
I don't know if they kept any of the
[ __ ] that was in the pool if they just
threw it all out because apparently it
was good stuff I mean it apparently was
all like new furniture and everything
like that it's like you
you think that you'd want to keep some
of it I mean I would anyway
so they hadn't been there very long
um when
that you know they were kind of getting
settled in and whatnot now John was at
the house by himself one day I think
he's just sitting out on the porch
drinking a beer or something like that
and I think Joyce was away she was at
the store at work or some [ __ ]
so uh this guy walks up to the house
and John said that he was just real kind
of like an old
he I don't know like he kind of looked
like a meth head from when I saw like a
bum you know what I mean like he had
like dirty clothes on it was all like
torn and tattered he had like kind of
rotten teeth like I said so like a meth
head and uh so he walks up to the house
and he's carrying a machete which is you
know that's that's never a good sign is
it
so John's like watching this guy coming
up on the property and you know this
isn't a this isn't a place where there's
like other stuff around where somebody
would just like wander onto your [ __ ]
you know what I mean it's just like
it's kind of out in the middle of
nowhere
so he's like uh you know can I like help
you with something or what's the deal
so the man evidently according to John
like points at the house with the
machete and he says I live here
so John is like
um
I you don't though like I bought the
house
you know I I don't know what he's like
well did the past owner let you live
here like what's the deal
so and he was like well maybe the guy
like squatted here or something you know
what I mean or maybe he was friends with
the with the with the other guy
so the guy this guy like just looks at
John and then he says I kill the
monsters
that's that's what he said okay see this
is automatically see this is like a
horror movie yeah I feel like they're
making it he's a Monster killer yeah you
got a crackhead rocks around [ __ ]
killing monsters
yeah okay
I'm seeing it
me too this would make a good haunting
episode it would actually well that's
kind of like the vibe I got when I was
first like reading about it
um I kill the monsters so John's like oh
okay
um but you know he doesn't want to like
antagonize this guy because you know he
looks kind of crazy and also he has a
machete on
so um he's like well tell you what um I
really don't think I need the services
of a Monster killer thank you very much
though
um you know I I own the place now and
I'll take care of it you know just like
don't worry about it so uh apparently
the guy wandered off and uh was never to
be seen again apparently so there's that
so uh evidently one of the things too
that he noticed and this is again very
much like a haunting
he was like he contacted the telephone
company like to get the phone hooked up
like I said it's the 90s you know so
before everybody had cell phones
so he makes an appointment for the phone
guy to come out and like hook the phone
up
so the time of the appointment comes and
the dude doesn't show up
so John as you would like calls the
telephone company he's like what the
[ __ ] like where where is the person so
they were like oh you know sorry uh
someone will be out there in a few days
you know really I promise
so again though the appointment time
came and went and again nobody shows up
so John really pissed now he calls the
phone company back and he's like what
the hell is like where is this person
and he's like you know he he went full
Karen and was like let me talk to your
supervisor
so the supervisor says oh well here's
what probably happened is that all of
our phone technicians are contract
employees you know what it means they
don't work there they just like call
them out and like send them out which is
kind of how most of that [ __ ] Works
nowadays
and they said probably what happened was
that they saw the address like on the
order and they were like yeah [ __ ] that
we're not going out there because
apparently what John learned before he
bought the or like you know after he had
already bought the place
was that oh this house this Ranch has a
little bit of a reputation like
everybody that lives around here
um one thing is that had been used as a
brothel reportedly which like I said who
cares about that I don't know but
apparently some people there's a big
[ __ ] dangerous [ __ ] home well yeah
I mean that's yeah yeah
um but then one of the other things
though like other than being a brothel
which isn't a big deal but apparently it
was the site of some kind of like
government raid kind of like along the
lines of like a Ruby Ridge or a Waco
type thing which I don't know it can't
have been that big of a deal because I
didn't really hear about it yeah it
would have been a scandal yeah
um so so a bunch of the locals around
there like however minor it was they
kind of thought oh the government came
in and like murdered people and all this
other kind of stuff so there was like a
bunch of conspiracy theories about that
and there was also a story I don't know
if it's true or not that a guy had kind
of went crazy in there like I don't know
if he lived there or whatever and had
shot himself now I've heard it was a
young guy and I've heard it was an old
guy so I don't know which one of those
is true
so
um also the over the next few months
that he lived there John starts hearing
stories about uh you know just among the
locals in town or whatever like talking
about you know UFO type stuff animal
mutilations that kind of thing
so he tries to like start asking people
around about it but nobody really
everyone kind of clams up they don't
really want to talk about it because I
guess they're scared or whatever
but then stuff starts happening
specifically to John
so one night
he's driving uh he was in town for
something and then he's driving back
home
and he sees a bunch of strange lights in
the sky
he said that it looked like the lights
were following each other like they were
all like attached to a single string
that's what he described it like
he said that they glowed like um orange
like orangish and that they were like
really really big and really bright so
it wasn't stars or nothing like that
so he said he watched them for quite a
while like while he was you know driving
and they kind of like went over the hill
or whatever
now apparently this was only the first
time that he saw them and like over the
next you know however long it was he
would see these kind of Lights a lot you
know what I mean
so because he kept seeing them I guess
he started
um kind of looking into the history of
the area a little bit
and evidently uh some other people had
reported seeing these weird lights uh in
the sky like over this area of Arizona
as well
um so I guess like the military came in
and like said that they investigated
because I guess there was a military
base about 12 miles away from the ranch
the berry Goldwater military base
and uh they came out and much like they
did in the Phoenix Lights because they
came out and said that they were flares
test flares
when she said
like lights on a string going over the
mountain and I was like well that's just
like the Phoenix light Phoenix Lights
that's the same state and everything
yeah so some morning bells are going off
I'm going like are you you're not
[ __ ] ripping off the Phoenix Lights
case are you well we'll see we'll see
well if he's ripping off anything he's
ripping off everything because it's like
freaking plates it's like there's all
kind of stuff right and then that famous
Phoenix Lights video
was within [ __ ] a few miles of an Air
Force uh Airport
the thing is though is that
the people that were part of the Phoenix
Lights incident
they saw those flares and they go yeah
that's not what we're talking about this
flares [ __ ] were put out hours after
the [ __ ] craft went over the air
force went up there and dropped those
damn flares
the flares was a cover story
you know the famous video of the Phoenix
Lights is flares
people that saw the UFO said no that's
not it that's not what we saw that was
the flares that they dropped later
and the same kind of thing happened here
because uh a lot of the locals like when
the military came out and said oh it was
just flares yeah like a lot of the
locals came out and said uh yeah well
you guys are always like spreading the
misinformation like that and that you
were trying to cover up like some weird
UFO stuff going on and they said look
we've seen flares in this area before we
know what flares look like and that's
not what we're seeing yeah it's [ __ ]
basic counterintelligence all right CIA
and [ __ ] does it
they do that kind of [ __ ] [ __ ]
military intelligence
if you get caught do something similar
to what you're being accused of
in that same area you go no no and then
use it as misdirection right it's
gaslighting I mean that's like the most
right that's what you do the best thing
you do you can do it with anything
Tom Sykes says John Edmonds said he and
his wife were driving back from the
movie theater in their convertible
Mustang and witnessed the Phoenix Lights
of course they did he wanted to get in
on everything I feel like yeah you know
what I mean so at this point uh John and
Joyce have lived at Stardust Ranch for
about three months
and then you get some as if like lights
in the sky wasn't enough now you get
like some weird Poltergeist type
activity starting to happen inside the
house
um he there was a lot of like uh
anomalies like with the electricity like
lights flashing on and off uh TVs going
on and off stuff like that by itself
um you got like uh the the plugs like
around the house the outlets yeah they
would um just stop working for no reason
and then start again uh same thing with
like their power tools and things like
that they would stop working and start
working like [ __ ] like that yeah and
then they noticed that stuff like little
objects and things were kind of like
disappearing like um you know mail or
car keys or something like that
um would disappear from the location
where they were and they would turn up
somewhere else like some time later
um and then some things would disappear
from their original location and then
several hours would they really pop up
back in the same location so it's UFO
and Poltergeist well oh yeah there's so
much more yeah there's all kind of like
fun stuff but I see I thought you would
enjoy the pair of the the Poltergeist
angle in this one he's read all the
books yeah like I said he wanted like
all it's like I said it's like skin
walker Ranch where it's like well
because it's like well UFO that's not
exciting enough we need to like add all
this other stuff right all this other
stuff so there was like very very clear
like Poltergeist activity happening in
the house right
keys and [ __ ] like that because you got
you had that happen and you're fully
yeah that was Poltergeist guys didn't
see any UFOs well yeah I'm just saying
well yeah but see I feel like sometimes
isn't there like a small percentage of
some like quote unquote Poltergeist case
or haunting cases where they try to like
tie it in
with a UFO thing it's like oh well in
this area like there's all this kind of
Haunting [ __ ] going on but then there's
also like people see weird lights in the
sky I'm gonna tie it in right now
he's gonna tie it should I put on a wig
oh that's what you need you need a tin
foil huh do we have any tin foil in the
kitchen we've got to
we might have wax paper you have a wax
paper hat
don't don't step on her don't step on
her snowman this white one
that's mine yeah yeah oh I don't think
you've ever worn that one actually I've
only worn it once I didn't like I didn't
really like it all that much but yeah
all right
I'm ready for my gay porn debut
what I think I get kicked out of any
game
what what gay porn Niche are you are you
I don't [ __ ] know
it's like it's like heavy metal Einstein
yeah yeah
now what was I talking about
no okay sexy yeah okay and tying it in
with UFO all right stuff
I've never witnessed [ __ ] UFO I wish
I would though I wish I could I want to
see that [ __ ] but I have seen
Poltergeist
one of the things that I [ __ ] noticed
is that
some some of the like descriptions of
things that you know of what a UFO could
do kind of reminds me a little bit of
how object would move during the
Poltergeist event
it makes you wonder if
mate extraterrestrials
when they're kind of traveling across
these vast distances in space if they
might be using the technology
that uses the same physics that happen
in a poltergeist
okay yeah in other words like
teleportation or objects passing through
other matter inner penetration of matter
because matter is mostly empty space
yeah it should pass through each other
but they don't there's other forces
involved which prevent it
but you might be able to bypass that
it's the same thing with space you know
under normal circumstances the quickest
distance the quickest Direction
from one point to another is a straight
line
but what if you made here and there the
same place you know what I mean like a
wormhole and just appeared and
disappeared that's what it would look
like to everybody else but you've gone
into a hyper Dimension and then back
down into this dimension
my idea is is that
what you see in a poltergeist case
might actually represent physics that
you might build and build a machine and
actually exploit that you know what I
mean
okay
Tom syk says we got Dr Emmett Emmett
Brown in the house
because El padrito just came in and said
good evening what the hell did I watch
well what I'm saying is if a human being
can cause a poltergeist event
why couldn't you do that techno with
technology
yeah you know that's what I'm saying
because there's some something that
having to do with the forces of nature
and physics there
so if it's if it's a reality then that
means you can build a machine that can
do that
which would be cool actually
[Music]
go to the restroom so uh so yeah so we
got some Poltergeist activity happening
like I said um probably as as you would
you kind of feel like uh yeah I just put
the keys down and then like you come
back and they're gone and then like an
hour later they turn up in the same
place like you think you're going nuts
like if that happens a few times I mean
I've had some weird [ __ ] like that
happen to you so I get it
so you know so John apparently was kind
of doing stuff where he's like okay I'm
gonna put this down right here I'm
telling myself right here that I'm
putting it right there and then he comes
back and it's gone but then like a few
hours later it'd be back again so he's
just like what the [ __ ] is going on in
this place
so
he also started reporting
um kind of like uh drastic temperature
changes in his house
um you know changes in like air pre like
you know the pressure barometric
pressure I'm assuming like stuff like
that
um he described it I'm I guess in his
book that you know like the barometric
pressure when it changes during a storm
and you get like that weird feeling like
a lot of times like before we had like
really bad storms I get like a really
bad migraine or something like that so I
guess it was kind of like that
so uh he also and this is also very
Poltergeist is that he started to notice
that when he was particularly stressed
out or angry or something like that that
it would trigger the you know the kind
of poltergeist activity like you'd get
like I said your electrical anomalies
like you know things turning on and off
by themselves like TVs and stuff like
objects disappearing
um you know [ __ ] falling off the table
like plates and things like that falling
off and breaking stuff like that and he
started to notice that it was doing that
more when he was angry or stressed out
so like I said that is very poltergeisty
um
so now we're getting to the part with
the little uh with the animals here
because he said what the hell she says
no what's it better no no daddy no yeah
she yelled but she was like she loves it
when I wrestle yeah we're playing we're
doing a show yeah okay
stop stop now look she's calling me to
come down
call me to come down
play with the toys just to go down there
and play with the toys yeah oh yeah she
loves her daddy yeah
but um but yeah so he noticed that the
animals were also behaving very
strangely like whenever any of this
stuff would happen like the pressure
changes and everything so he knew that
he wasn't just crazy that he wasn't just
imagining it because the animals were
like where what the [ __ ] going on the
same kind of thing
so yeah so like I said this is where the
where the [ __ ] up stuff starts
happening to animals so I'm just telling
you ahead of time I'm just I'm just
making myself feel better by saying
maybe this none of this happened and
it's not real but so he's John one night
is walking around checking on uh all his
animals
and he had like a bunch of kennels like
for his all of his Rottweilers that he
had
and he got there and he found one of the
doors of the kennel kennels was open
so he goes in and he finds one of the
dogs dead
and the dog is like completely
smushed like completely flat but like no
blood or got squirted out or nothing
like that like you know what I mean
which like I said sounds a little
so I would switch squished flat it was
still where was it squished like in a
cart like in the kennel yeah like in a
cartoon like in a cartoon when like when
like the [ __ ] yeah
when the when the steamroller goes over
you I guess do they have a photo that's
what I pictured did they have a
photograph of it of course not where's
the body well yeah that's what I'm
saying I'm just saying he's made it yeah
because if some paranormal [ __ ] happens
and I've seen paranormal [ __ ] we tried
to take pictures of every [ __ ] thing
we try to catch things happening in the
moment that happened there couldn't
catch them but we took pictures
you know and if we ever had something
like that if we ever came across a dog
that was squished flat we would have
saved it put it in a damn Ziploc bag
freezer or in the freezer yeah so he's
like look at this weird [ __ ] yeah so
it's yeah no I don't believe that Holy
parachute him said Acme safe falls from
the sky that's kind of what I was
expecting
I was thinking about like a cartoon
um so what did they do with the body did
they say no see yeah conveniently we're
not going to talk well see there's a lot
of convenient stuff yeah we're gonna
talk about what we do with the body
um yeah Tom Sykes said same thing
happened at Skinwalker Ranch the dogs
were vaporized into liquid mush yeah
that's right I had forgotten about that
did they get a sample
probably not well now we are going to
get into that a little bit later because
there was some samples happening but
we'll we'll talk about that in a little
bit okay so yeah so John says his dogs
like smushed flat but there's no there's
nothing around the animal that like
would imply that there had been anything
around there yeah
um and he said he hadn't heard any of
the other dogs barking
uh you know they were all out in the
kennel so I'm assuming they were just
like oh my God it's herb it's like you
just got flattened and then like they
didn't say anything about it you know
what I mean
um and a bunch of other animals
reportedly on the ranch uh would also
die in a similarly weird ways like there
wouldn't be any noise like they're like
the animals wouldn't get upset or
anything like that he would just like
find him dead and they would be like
mutilated like in weird ways like one of
the horses supposedly
um or maybe more than one but I he would
sometimes find the horses dead and like
they had like their eyes missing and
like their tongues missing and stuff
like that which like I said that's
pretty common in like cattle mutilation
type yeah well I got something to say
about that yeah
yeah if you come up around Farms I've
been around Farms of course you know my
family's been involved with them forever
the horse industry
find a dead animal which is kind of it's
kind of rare in the industry but you do
find dead animals
um things like that are going to happen
depending on what the weather is what
what type of year what the environment
is is like in the South they decompose
quickly
but just because the eye is gone that
doesn't mean that an alien got it
because the birds will go after that
first
they go after the damn eye that's facing
up or up they can get to that one so
there's a lot of stuff that and tongues
are soft and they can get to that [ __ ]
like that other little animals can you
know
fox or
raccoons you know they'll go for [ __ ]
like that because it's a little more
tender you know so there's an order in
which things get eaten
it doesn't mean anything
I've seen some of the so-called cattle
mutilation cattle and it just looks like
normal predation to me or normal
Scavenging but it looks like to me but
just saying
she also claimed that some of the dead
animals but like I said conveniently
doesn't seem to have any photos or
anything like that of it
um seemed like they had like uh very
precise Cuts taken out of them like with
sections their bodies removed like with
no blood
so there was that it means it was done
poor post modem that's all that means
well yeah you can cut some off a dead
creature and it doesn't bleed yeah just
a lot of the [ __ ] that I've seen over
the years
from the cattle mutilation scene I'm not
convinced it looks like normal
Scavenging
um things do come off kind of straight
when some somebody rips a piece off of
an animal you know
or dog does it
it just it does and there's bloat
involved sometimes which helps kind of
straighten it out looking it people
don't know what dead animals look like
you know that's all it is
perhaps so
the only thing that looks [ __ ] the
only thing that looked unusual to me is
that one in one of those cattle
mutilation cases
they showed a piece of cowhide
that was looked like it was cut in a
zigzag pattern
you know like that mm-hmm and it was
they said well it's slightly burned
and I was looking at it and I was going
like nuts you know those special [ __ ]
fabric shears
that do like pinking shears pinking
shears yeah yeah you could tell that's
what somebody used on them I bet you you
could get picking shears that would line
right up with that which means hoax yeah
I mean you can buy painting shears
anywhere right I used to have a couple
pairs of them
but they were trying to make it look
like a laser beam went down there and
did a zigzag cut yeah yeah
like a laser would anybody that went to
like Joanne Fabrics yeah you look is
there anything be like those are pinking
shirts yeah but yeah
yeah you could buy this for like five
dollars yeah
um but yeah so uh I also want to note
here when we'll get into this late well
I don't know if I want to spoil this now
but like yeah so we're finding like um
to dead animals and stuff
so also around this time uh John and
Joyce started waking up in the morning
with uh weird marks on their bodies like
weird cuts and bruises and all this
other kind of stuff
so they started to suspect that
something was like sneaking into their
house at night and like [ __ ] with
them you know what I mean
so basically John at this point is like
yeah I'm pretty sure like some
paranormal Shenanigans are going on uh
Joyce she was kind of like well I'm not
really convinced because she didn't see
a lot of the same stuff that he saw I
guess
um because she was at work like most of
the day so he saw a lot more stuff than
she did so John starts kind of getting
freaking out and he's like you know
getting paranoid and stuff so he starts
like uh essentially like stockpiling
weapons he's got like guns and knives
and baseball bats and he's just like got
him like everywhere around like they're
by the bed they're by the you know
anywhere he goes he has like stuff like
that just in case you know what I mean
so uh one evening this is a pretty this
is this is also like a really good
horror story prompt I thought
so one night uh John and Joyce are gonna
go into town and they're gonna have
dinner
so John got ready first and he was like
waiting for Joyce to finish getting
ready so he's just out in the living
room watching TV or whatever
10 minutes later Joyce comes out the
bedroom
um and John's like wow she's awfully
dressed up it's like we weren't going to
like the [ __ ] Ritz or anything like
that they were just going to like some
local Mexican restaurant or something
it's like it wasn't super fancy but she
looked like super fancy and he's just
like okay whatever like he didn't really
like question it right you know even
though he did kind of like wonder about
it
so they get in the car and they go to
the restaurant and they sit down and
they order food like you do at a
restaurant
and then before the food came uh Joyce
is like oh I'm gonna go to the bathroom
so she gets up to go to the bathroom
so John's sitting there and he starts
looking at his phone
and then when he looks at his phone he
has a bunch of missed phone calls from
his home phone number which I'm assuming
is a landline because I think this is
still the 90s at this point
so he's like wait what the [ __ ] like
nobody's home so who the [ __ ] is calling
me from my home phone
so he calls the home phone and Joyce
picks up the phone from the house Joyce
who is supposed to be at the restaurant
with him and is in the bathroom hmm and
uh she says where did you go you just
left me here
and he's like
um what are you talking about it's like
you're at the restaurant with me like
right now you just went to the bathroom
and then it it occurs to him that he's
like well I guess I didn't really look
at her all that closely like you know
what I mean so this whoever this is
comes out of the bathroom
and he looks at her like really really
closely because Joyce says on the phone
it's like I'm at home I came out of the
bedroom like to leave and you were
already you'd already left like you know
what I mean and she's like and I
couldn't figure out what the [ __ ] was
going on so I kept calling you
so the so the woman comes back out the
bathroom
and he's like staring at her
and then he says that he looked at her
really close and he immediately knew
he's like oh my God that's not her even
though it looked like her but I guess it
wasn't her
so I guess while he was still thinking
that guess what happened just like in a
horror movie Her Eyes turned completely
black not just the whole eye you know
what I mean
um and then she just like stared at him
like what are you gonna do about it
[ __ ]
really
that says
it really happened but it's like that's
a great that'd be a great [ __ ] uh
story anyway I'm really into like the
whole doppelganger thing that's like
really really creepy to me
so uh apparently he sees this happen and
he's like yep and he just like nope the
[ __ ] out of there
and he gets back in the truck and he
rushes back home
leaving leaving this weird alien
doppelganger woman like in the
restaurant I guess I don't know what she
did afterward
so he gets home and he tells Joyce what
happened and she's like yeah we need to
get the [ __ ] out of here because that's
crazy
but um yeah John was like yeah but I
don't want to go though because this is
my house and you know I'm not really
like letting whatever this is like you
know kick me out or whatever even though
you think normal people if that happened
I'd be like yeah I think we should
probably leave
so um evidently this whole doppelganger
thing uh this happened like more than
once I guess so where he would see a
doppelganger of his wife and civilian
did it like it wasn't her so I don't
know what that was about but yeah
um also the other Paranormal Activity
like in the house and stuff like the
disappearances and whatnot like started
getting worse and worse
um to a point where sometimes stuff
would disappear
and then like later on it would like
fall out of midair like onto their heads
and stuff you know what I mean like
while they were looking for it yeah
which like I said is very Poltergeist
and well and like what I was saying
earlier was that he noticed that it
would get worse like when he was mad or
something yeah which like I said is the
same he's been reading books about that
guy well yeah
foreign
said that reminds me of that scene in
Lost Highway yeah I mean this is very
well because David Lynch really likes
that whole doppelganger thing because he
knows that doppelgangers are that's
creepy
there's something really creepy about
somebody that is you or is it but is not
you or like you know I would be like
really freaked out if like you went to
dinner with like your who you thought
was your spouse
and then your actual spouse called and
is like you know what the [ __ ] where'd
you go like and now who the [ __ ] is this
now it's just like staring at you across
the table that's like pretty freaky
so uh so yeah so all of this stuff like
you know falling out there on their
heads and whatever
so John
um had actually kept he had like a
baseball bat like right by the side of
his bed and like I said him both him and
Joyce reportedly have been waking up
with all of these cuts and bruises and
[ __ ] like that like all over them but he
had never like whenever it was being
done to him evidently like I guess it
never woke him up
but
John was thinking well just on the off
chance that I do wake up and catch some
little [ __ ] doing this stuff to
me while I'm sleeping then I'm just
gonna like bash him right the [ __ ] in
the head with the baseball bat
so uh one night he reported that he woke
up he did wake up like around three in
the morning and he said that he felt
like this little like a little hand like
kind of messing with his arm like the
inner part of his forearm
so he jumps out of bed he grabs the
baseball bat and swings it at whatever
the [ __ ] was touching his arm
and he said that he heard
a hissing sound like uh sound like when
you release helium out of a balloon like
a kind of noise I guess it sounded like
that sounded like that
so
um at this point it's this is going in a
very communion Direction right now if
you guys that remember that Whitley
streamer book
so after he did that and heard the
little balloon sound
then he said that he could see three
little
alien creatures looking at him little
Grace in his room
and they looked like Grace you know what
I mean they had big heads and the big
black eyes and all that other kind of
stuff and little bitty skinny bodies
he said there was three of them standing
in his room
and that a second after he actually like
saw them that they just like disappeared
you know what I mean like they just
moved into like a dead Dimension or
something
so after this sighting
John says well maybe the reason that we
have all these cuts and bruises and [ __ ]
that we wake up with maybe they're like
abducting us during the night so like I
said this is like communion because he's
stealing from that too because that's
what we Whitley strieber said happened
also that like the aliens would come and
like abduct him and
do stuff to you like in the night and he
didn't remember
um so they said though like neither one
of them said that they could remember
anything in particular that happened but
they said well when we did research
about other people that said that they
had been you know abducted that it was
the same kind of thing it's like they
have all these scars and wounds and
missing time and all this other kind of
stuff but they didn't like they couldn't
remember like what had happened to them
so they were like oh okay well that that
checks out like that lines up because
that's exactly what had happened to that
so apparently though now that John has
seen the little Fellers
um they were like okay well I guess he's
seen us now so we're just gonna like run
around all free you know what I mean
because he said after this point he
started to see the little [ __ ] all
the time and like just running around
the [ __ ] just like in the house like
they'd be peeking around the walls and
stuff and we like running around the
ranch and whatnot and he said that he
would
he tried to like kill him like he tried
to he would throw [ __ ] at him or like
shoot at him or [ __ ] like that Whitley
streamer yeah that's what I just said
yeah yeah that's what I just yeah yeah
he's going with the streamer
you can't fool us we know all these
I I know I've read all this [ __ ]
everybody out of [ __ ] yeah I know where
you're getting all these details from
yeah
so yeah so um he says that he's doing
all this stuff but it didn't really ever
seem to hurt them like a lot of times
like he would just throw some [ __ ] at
him and they would just go Boop and they
would just like vanish or whatever or
they would just kind of like hiss at him
and then be like they come up they put
they put the vacuum cleaner [ __ ] hose
up in his booty
he'd look at him and he goes how big
how dare you that is one of the funniest
[ __ ] scenes in any movie ever been
made
I mean Christopher Walken can play off
anal violation man so [ __ ] funny he
did it in two movies Joseph did it in
[ __ ] Pulp Fiction Pulp Fiction
he was like
yeah this is a very butt-centric career
no no I'm thinking now that I'm thinking
about it a [ __ ] vacuum of alien
vacuum cleaner hose came out of the wall
went up into his [ __ ] booty and he
looked at the [ __ ] alien he looked at
the alien [ __ ] queen or whatever it
was and goes how dare you
like he was serious you know what I mean
how dare you how dare you stick it back
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
[ __ ] awesome
if you watched that movie yeah we did
that's like the funniest [ __ ] because
you could tell that [ __ ] walking was
on the verge of [ __ ] busted up like
well how could you not laughing
what kind of material is this
oh how far my career has fallen well I
think one of for me like the funniest
part of that I mean that part was funny
but the funniest thing to me was that I
love the idea that the aliens just had
this anal probe just like in the wall
like that like it was just real
convenient and I don't know why that was
like so funny to me because like the
implication being that it's like yeah
they have people up to like anal probe
them all the time so it's like we always
just like to have the anal probe thing
just like right there at hand because
you never know
you never know and you're just gonna
have to like pull it out the wall and
it'll throw something so they always
have to happen
it was like looking it's like having the
Roomba you know what I mean like right
there but it was just like in the wall
it's like that just that was like
funnier to me than like the whole just
imagining that scenario like [ __ ]
cracked me up I was like looking and
they have the whole [ __ ] [ __ ] set up
right there it's like
oh whatever but yeah so
um I'm not really sure like I think Tom
Sykes said earlier that um that uh that
John Edmonds said that the that the um
aliens had like actually
sexually violated his wife but that he
didn't really like to talk about it I
don't know if that's the case or not
like I said um he did write a book and
I'm assuming that he put a lot of
details in there but like I said I
wasn't paying ten dollars for it and I
couldn't like a lot of times if you go
to Amazon's like sometimes they'll let
you read some of it like for free but um
yeah they wouldn't let me do that and I
was like man that's it's a little
expensive I'm not going to read that
because I kind of felt like it probably
wasn't worth it but I don't know
but I mean that sounds like some [ __ ]
that that the aliens would do in this
situation and they absolutely did do
that in communion and if that's and this
sounds very communion-like so I'm
thinking that that's probably
you know that's probably where that went
you know what I mean I'm just I was just
telling them that it's like I thought
the funniest thing about that was that
the aliens had the anal probe thing like
right there just like handy yeah you
know what I mean just because you never
know when you're when you're gonna need
something that's part of their MO you
know what I mean they picked you up
shine some lights on your eyes and [ __ ]
like that and look at you and put some
up in your booty
and then they drop it back on
that's all we want yeah
I don't know what that was
well maybe the aliens they're from a
planet where they have like a they have
like an anal like a fetish yeah of some
kind yeah and it's just kind of like
that's all they care about they don't
care about scientific experimentation or
nothing like that they're just really
really into like sticking vacuum
cleaners up human yeah it's a fact
definitely a vacuum cleaner hose well
that's what it was in the movie for sure
yeah it was a vacuum hose it's just oh
my God out there and [ __ ] then
walking looks at the camera and goes how
dare you
foreign
that movie's a piece of [ __ ] what's
funny is that it could have been great
it's almost great
but it isn't it it's almost crazy
yeah it could have been it could have
been but the material they were working
with there was not movable
I mean anything like that is just gonna
be funny and I mean it can be done
um you know getting abducted by aliens
and having them [ __ ] with you I mean
that can be scary because they did it in
Fire in the Sky yeah it was partially
skipped that was scary parts of it were
but then when he's abducted then they
got these short little weird looking
green monsters aliens that are like
short and fat squat with the human faces
on them remember they were dancing
what the [ __ ] is going on it's a bizarre
[ __ ] movie yeah I had forgot I did
not take acid and watch that movie you
probably lose your [ __ ] mind yeah
no it's a real movie
it exists yeah it might still be on 2B I
think that's where we watched it so it's
probably free if you want to watch I
mean I don't I wouldn't advise anybody
to watch it but
I don't know get drunk and watch it it's
a pretty fun time yeah it's it's a fun
time because you can't believe that
anybody thought that that would that
that would be a good idea to make it
a dropped acid got high with my first
wife [ __ ] tip and we watched a movie
called Orlando
I thought I [ __ ] hallucinated that
[ __ ] where where she turned into from a
man to a woman and she was CH and she
would live for [ __ ] hundreds of years
and everything I thought I had
hallucinated all that but that actually
was the movie yeah it was a Trip movie
it had good music
the music and it was good yeah Gavin
Friday yeah there you go did it it's a
gay movie I guess I don't know movie
[Laughter]
it was a good movie though
uh El Padrino's that have either of you
seen a ghost or just felt a presence
um I have not
right here Tom has so I pulled you guys
standing ghost well I think I saw a
ghost you never saw an apparition you
never saw it no no
this is years after the after Mammoth
Mountain Poltergeist case it happened
Jane wrote a book by
my buddy uh Eric we got out of the army
like within a couple days with each
other
he waited a couple days for for uh for
me to get out
and we went to Boston together because
he had he had lived there before I never
lived there and at the time I had a
girlfriend living up in there she was a
Tufts University
so I linked back up with her that [ __ ]
didn't work out
uh not not long term
good thing though what happened to her
later but anyway
um
we ended up moving in this [ __ ] old
Victorian house it was in um now it was
not Somerville next to Somerville
Medford I think is what I think I think
was the town
I think it was Medford
I could fight it on the map but I forgot
the address and that house was [ __ ]
evil and it just it just had a [ __ ]
felt like you were being watched in
there and [ __ ] had really bad dreams
and uh we'd bring girls over and they
would be like they you'd have to walk
them to the [ __ ] bathroom and [ __ ]
guard them on the outside while they
were taking a leak and [ __ ] it's just
that was a [ __ ] wild ass house but we
never saw anything it was always it was
just feelings
you know
and that that house is old over a
hundred years at that time
so I don't know never saw any
apparitions never heard any voices I
felt like I came under like attack but
it was like a psychic Attack One Time
felt like something's spinning around me
and
like there was something
like someone was watching me you know
and it was something like impressing you
but it could it was just emotion though
you couldn't see anything
yeah I think nothing ever moved so it
always had plausible deniability you
know it was like is my is it my
imagination
but I'd already seen a poltergeist and
Poltergeist actually throw objects and
move objects and move things they have
that same feeling of being watched kind
of deal presence but
with that one I never really could I'm
pretty sure it was there Manor because
everybody else felt it
but there was never any concrete proof
to me
because I never saw anything move
you know
might have just had an impressive I
don't know the place was strong with the
dark side maybe that'd be a good place
to put it I mean I I've felt like you
know every now and then was like oh I
felt like somebody was in the room or
like behind me or something like that
and they weren't like I've had that
happen but not very much like I had it
happen one time pretty strongly like at
my grandmother's house which is weird
because I never thought the house was
haunted or nothing like that but it's
like I was just sitting at the dining
room table one day and felt like someone
was standing right behind me but nobody
was there but that's like the strongest
time that I've ever felt that I haven't
usually felt that now the interesting
thing is that they can actually
stimulate some parts of your brain
and give you that feeling
um you know just by doing that so it's
obviously some part of your brain that's
firing for whatever reason
um because they can replicate that like
in a lab but
that doesn't mean there's nothing there
I'm just saying that they can do that so
I don't know if it's just some [ __ ]
glitch or because I've I've very very
rarely had that happen the one strongest
time I had it happen I was at my
grandmother's house and I felt like
somebody was standing like literally
right behind me
and I was like what the [ __ ] and then
and then nobody was there because I
thought like it was my brother or
something like that but nobody was there
so I've had that happen but I never seen
anything I've I actually don't really I
haven't really met that many people that
said they've seen an actual Apparition
yeah even my my mom and her sisters and
stuff like that who grew up in my
grandfather's old house which was
supposedly haunted and they reported
they could hear things like they heard
footsteps like somebody in Boots walking
around the roof all the time and they
had like their covers torn off and
everything but I don't think any of them
ever actually saw anything like a ghost
I mean
yeah that one house in Medford
the thing that would get you would be
like
just out of the blue you're walking from
one part of the house to another and you
got to go through a damn hallway
and you're going halfway down through
the hallway and all of a sudden you slow
down you feel like there's something
right in front of you
you know you don't see anything but you
just feel like there's something there
and you press through it and you feel
you're so freaked out and scared you
feel like your head is spinning and then
you're out of it you're like whoa whoa
whoa and then you kind of run from it a
little bit like there was something
there
but you couldn't see anything yeah it
was just
weird yeah it's a creepy sensation like
there was something there like there was
something standing there in that hallway
but you couldn't see it and you passed
it you went through it
yeah Al padrino said yeah I felt that
yeah I think a lot of people have
but it's just like like you said you
don't know if it's real because it's
like you can't see anything
you can't say anything objective didn't
do anything physical right so like I
said it could just I mean it could very
well just be your brain glitching out or
something yeah and giving you that
sensation because they can give you that
sensation in a lab so but I had seen
Poltergeist before and that could move
objects and parts of poltergeist felt
like that yeah but you know and it
wasn't just me it was other people but a
lot of people report that as like um in
haunting cases or Poltergeist cases
that's the first thing they feel like is
they feel like they're being watched or
like there's like somebody in the room
that they can't see you know what I mean
yeah looking down on you from above yeah
but so uh yeah so where was I okay so
John's like throwing stuff at the aliens
and um they're just going and like
disappearing because you know they're
just he's just making them mad
so uh so yeah so I guess John and Joyce
are still sleeping in the house but he
now he's like waking up all the time
because you know he's he's wondering if
these little [ __ ] are like wandering
in his room and like kidnapping them and
[ __ ] like that
so one night he wakes up and his wife
Joyce is levitating above the bed you
know it happens sometimes
so he tried to wake her up uh but it
didn't work so you know she's like you
know yelling at her and shaking her and
stuff but she didn't wake up
um he she did open her eyes but she was
like looking at him all blank and he
actually tried to he pushed her back
down onto the bed right and then she
basically you know he pushed her down
she like looked at him but he she wasn't
responding and then when she got back in
bed she basically just like turned over
and went back to sleep and then he asked
her about it the next morning and she
didn't know what he was talking about so
she didn't like remember it
so he said that this happened a whole
bunch of times
and he said that each time that it would
happen his wife would kind of
this is a little excited it's so funny
um each time that it happened like his
wife would kind of like float farther
and farther away from the bed you know
what I mean and at one point she's even
starting to kind of float out the room
and like toward the front door of the
house right
and so each time this happened because
obviously he kept waking up so he would
like try to wake her up and then she
would just sit up and she was like kind
of in a weird Fugue or she was like in a
weird trance or whatever and she would
just like make her way back to the
bedroom so he was like why are you
floating all around the house or
whatever
so one night he decides he see he wakes
up and he sees her you know levitating
out of the room like usual and he's like
I'm gonna follow her and see what
happens
so he starts following her so she's like
floating down the hallway
and he said that there was like a beam
of light that was like attached like it
was pulling her you know what I mean
and then suddenly he says she was pulled
through the wall
as if the wall was not solid yeah we
okay that also happened in the uh
infield case well yeah that too when uh
little what's her name the little girl
said she was in bed and she rolled over
and went through the wall and ended up
in the in the apartment next door but
she had some evidence she had a book in
her hand and that book was found in the
apartment next door
she left the book behind
so there was some cooperation with that
and there was a lot of you know the cops
saw that one cops in the newspapers not
that particular event but they knew
about that they knew about that case
they saw some [ __ ] happen
he's been reading a bunch of books
I kind of feel I don't remember trying
to make a granddaddy of all cases I
don't remember if in communion if
anybody ever actually went through a
wall but I thought I remembered
something like that yeah unless I'm
because I read the book but it was a
long time ago he's [ __ ]
so yeah so apparently um his wife just
got stuck through the wall like what is
the thing so he goes out the door and
goes out the front yard
and then he sees like a big like a UFO
you know what I mean so he sees like a
big disc shaped UFO about 100 feet off
the ground
um and his wife's being like sucked up
into it just like your classic
you know your class your classic getting
sucked into the into the [ __ ] and uh
it's fun I don't know if you guys have
seen it was where I used to work we had
this lamp
that was the top of the lamp was a UFO
and the the
um the body of the lamp was a beam yes
and then there was a cow suspended it
was the best lamp ever I don't remember
where they got I think they just got it
from Amazon it was like so [ __ ] funny
it wasn't like really bright or anything
but yeah it was just like this Beam with
like a little cow
and the top of the lamp was like [ __ ]
it was so funny it was like the most
awesome lamp ever you could probably
still get them I don't think they're so
okay so this part You're gonna laugh at
this part I just know I just know you
are
so so yeah so he goes outside sees his
wife floating up toward this big mother
ship or whatever
so
um he he pulled the Tom and ran back in
the house and got his AK yeah and
started shooting at the UFO with the AKA
because you know yeah
um so I guess the the aliens were just
kind of like well [ __ ] bro that's that's
all you had to do so it actually let
Joyce go I don't know if it dropped her
like I don't know how far she was off
the ground she was like bam like hit the
[ __ ] floor I don't know
um yeah so she got dropped to the ground
so um apparently though she actually did
remember this happening because remember
they said that she'd have this had
happened a lot of times to her before
and she didn't remember it but she said
this time she did actually remember that
she got sucked out and then him like
shooting at it or whatever
so not too long after this John starts
posting online about stuff that's
happening at the ranch like I guess like
looking for help or whatever
um and apparently though after he shot
at the UFO I guess the aliens were like
all right dude like chill out or
whatever because they stopped trying to
abduct anybody and like stop [ __ ]
with them while they were sleeping I
guess and like all the weird paranormal
[ __ ] that was happening around the house
kind of like it was still going on but
not as bad you know what I mean
so uh at this point though
um he sees something else
he sees something else uh some some new
Wrinkle in this whole case
so he's walking around uh the property
like checking everything out which is
something that he had taken to doing
and while he's walking around he sees
a 10 to 12 foot tall creature walking
upright
what he sees essentially I'm kind of
thinking I'm thinking he saw a Sasquatch
10 to 12 feet tall that's what he's
saying he's saying it's a Sasquatch I
don't know if he actually it's desert
Sasquatch how did he describe it but he
said okay
they said well the thing about it was
he'd seen so much weird [ __ ] around this
he's just like oh you know Bigfoot of
course yeah but um he started calling it
The Michelin Man because I guess it was
like round of like or fat or whatever
and it was like really big
and he said that he saw it a bunch of
times
um and it kind of was even kind of close
to the house sometimes and he shot at it
but the creature didn't really seem all
that phased by that okay so it doesn't
have hair on it like he said that it
looked like the skin had what he called
the texture of a Brillo pad
which doesn't exactly sound like a
Sasquatch unless it's a weird light it's
a Sasquatch with mange he saw the Stay
Puft Marshmallow Man
with mange yeah I thought that what it
was I'm like I don't know
she's trying to shoe horn [ __ ]
Sasquatch well see that's what I was
thinking because there is a lot of you
know a lot of the UFO cases they always
try to like put Bigfoot in there too
because they want Bigfoot to also be
like an extraterrestrial or an
interdimensional being and that's why
nobody sees and that's why nobody can
find the Bigfoot is because they're you
know going in and out of like wormholes
or whatever or they're from space I
don't know isn't that a whole thing
where they're the where they try to like
hook those two things up no I don't know
hooking up what again Bigfoot and
bigfooted Aliens yeah yeah yeah like I
said there's ghosts with that there's a
whole sub-genre where they're just like
everything is like one they're trying to
get it all into one phenomenon yeah
James they could be the king of the
[ __ ] show
we got it all figured out
you know yeah it's like the grand
overarching theory of paranormal
everything let me get it all figured out
but it's all the one thing it's not
though
[ __ ] no
it's not nothing's ever that simple come
on yeah I would have thought that out of
all these [ __ ] paranormal phenomenons
that Bigfoot would be the most likely
one to be something that really exists
see I would go with that too because but
like I said if Bigfoot exists it's not
like it's just like an animal yeah or
like a male-like animal the more I look
into the details
of what it actually takes and where
these
where these sightings came from I would
say that no Bigfoot doesn't exist
a lot of them were taking place some of
them were taking place in the South and
places in the United States where
if you look at a map there's nothing but
roads around there that thing would be
crossing the road all the time there's
no there's no real woods or Forest not
any Big Forest
so it couldn't exist there it would have
left an environmental impact and there'd
have to be a breeding population which
means that there's a lot of them you'd
see them all the time like Bears we see
Bears all the [ __ ] time they're in a
[ __ ] driveway waiting for us
you have something like a like a
Sasquatch no they'd leave a huge impact
on the environment you think because
they're big
yeah and intelligent they'd be
interacting with stuff trying to steal
food and stuff you'd see them all the
time
the only place something like that could
exist inside the United States would be
up somewhere near Washington State and
some of those forests like some of the
Nationals yeah it's like I could see
that but even then even then you'd
probably see something pick up [ __ ] like
that on [ __ ] satellites body heat you
know something you they couldn't stay
hidden for long
and if they're in a place like
Washington State you're forgetting about
[ __ ] Canada almost all of Canada's
like that that's a big area
but there's people there
it couldn't stay hidden
it couldn't stay hidden not for long not
with today's technology yeah maybe back
in the old days yeah back in the old
days no it's not there
stuff like that did exist with like
what's called Gigantopithecus
that was something kind of like a big
Bigfoot but that was
hundreds of thousands of years ago
it's just some kind of race memory that
people carry that yeah there was like a
man but bigger a lot of hair on it it's
kind of a no-brainer you might come up
with something like that you know wild
man well yeah it's not that it's not
that weird well because like I said you
know yeah things like that did exist at
some point now the gorilla
at one time was Legend it wasn't until
fairly recently that they actually
captured the white man captured a
gorilla and brought it to [ __ ]
they're like New York like look they're
it's real
a wild man a man with [ __ ] an animal
man
uh but the novelty of that wore off
pretty quickly they go yeah it's called
a gorilla now it's okay boring Africans
for [ __ ] thousands of years okay
that's not new all right just they're
like yeah what's the big deal
white people didn't know about him yeah
that's all that [ __ ] was
so
it could be also that
stories about Sasquatch are really just
based upon stories about gorillas
because there was a time in which
guerrillas weren't believed in yeah now
like no that doesn't exist but it did
because gorillas are very human-like
yeah and you have to go find them
you know back in those days
now we know where they live so it's
easier to get there
but you got you know African forest
rangers watching out for them and [ __ ]
Park Rangers
Tom Sykes says prehistoric humans look
like Bigfoot kind of yeah that's what
I'm saying so it's like it might just be
a memory of that James Knapp says if
Bigfoot exists it's likely a human
cousin like Neanderthal but uh I'm like
Tom hard to think that there are
bigfoots in the southern U.S they're
they'd have them in trash cans all the
time yep that's what I'm saying like
especially around here like [ __ ] man we
just had a bear in the trash can just a
couple days ago you'd hit them with cars
yeah you know because they wouldn't I
mean why would they hide yeah they just
like they'd just be coming out looking
for food like all the other creatures
it's just like there's no nothing in
Loch Ness
if there was a live Nest monster
for there to be a Loch Ness monster
there would have to be a bunch of them
to have a breeding population and they'd
be big based upon the description they
would be hiding they'd be laying up on a
bank splashing around
yeah like I said why would they hide
from people like the creatures don't
hide they don't give a [ __ ]
yeah they're like what are you gonna do
I'm just yeah you know become a [ __ ]
with me I'm just gonna step on it right
yeah though I wish there was a Loch Ness
monster yeah it'd be a lot more of a
mysterious world when I was a kid I
believed in the Loch Ness monster that
yeah there might be something down there
hiding it's mysterious
but that's not the way animals work yeah
animals animals don't have any sense of
like oh I'm so mysterious no
they just run around and run around
doing their own [ __ ] eating and
pooping and doing whatever there's not
enough food in Loch Ness there's not
enough biomass there it's cold and it's
deep in certain areas there's nothing at
the bottom you can take a [ __ ]
submarines have gone down there to see
what's at the bottom of [ __ ] a Loch Ness
there's not much food in there and I
don't even think there's that many fish
compared to you know how big that thing
is there's fish in it but the the fish
aren't very big there's just not enough
food there to support something that big
you know yeah much less like a whole
bunch of them yeah
yeah because they're talking about like
dinosaurs eyes which is massive yeah and
that means and and for there to be a
massive dinosaur-sized creature there
had to be a whole breeding population so
you're talking about dozens and dozens
of them yeah you need a ton of biomass
yeah and there's not enough food for
that many
because they would have to eat like a
it's just an amazing amount yeah and
then they could then they'd have to
avoid in interbreeding so you're talking
about dozens of them and there's just
not enough food there so no
we know how ecology works now you know
what I mean it's just a Helen make us
some more drinks all right yeah
so uh so yeah Brillo pad monster is is
what this was but like I said I'm
guessing it was like a Bigfoot or a
Sasquatch type of thing
um but I've never heard him described as
like having Brillo pad skin before but
all right
so uh as if aliens poltergeists and uh
possibly Bigfoot wasn't enough
couple months after the Bigfoot
sightings started
John's sitting in his backyard
just hanging out doing his thing
and a black SUV pulls up to his front
gate
and guess who this is that's right it's
the Men in Black
so two guys with black suits on and
black hats and black sunglasses your
classic Men in Black
they come out this SUV
so John who it was him and his neighbor
who was like sitting on the porch with
him I guess so they like watched the
dudes come up to the gate
and they said that the guys just walked
through the gate like they didn't open
it and walk through they just like
walked through like they were like it
wasn't there you know what I mean
um
so John said that they were very pale
and they s and said that their skin
looked like raw chicken skin is what he
said it looked like
so one of the dudes just kind of hung
back but the other one like walks right
up to John and like leans in and says to
him
you will stop posting your experiences
online that's what he said because
remember how I said that John had been
like talking about uh all the stuff that
was going on at the ranch that online so
this guy came up and said that to him
like and he said he said it in like this
really weird like creepy flat tone right
so John's like what like like what did
you say and he said the guy said it
again like in the exact same tone like
you will stop posting your experiences
online that's what he said
and then the two guys just like turned
around and left and again they walked
like through the fence like they didn't
open the fence they just or the gate
rather they just like walked through it
like it wasn't there like they were made
of smoke or something and then they
apparently just got in the car and in
the SUV and then just like drove off so
yeah Men In Black also I forgot to
mention
that there was also Men In Black
involved
so John's like okay well fair enough so
he apparently decided that he wasn't
going to post online anymore about all
of the stuff that was going on
um I don't know like they didn't
I guess he they didn't threaten him like
they didn't say what would happen like
if he didn't stop they just I guess it
creeped him out enough that he just
decided he was gonna stop
so so yeah so he's not talking about it
anymore and at this point it's just like
he just doesn't know what to do
um he had gotten where the drinks go oh
yeah well I had to go to the restroom
too he walks in like and he's just like
come in like with no drinks
um but yeah
so at this point he's just kind of like
uh he's getting pretty mad at these
[ __ ] aliens man because they're not
only you missed the whole Men In Black
situation okay he also had Men In Black
and Wrongs that came to the house and
told him to quit talking online about
the [ __ ] that was going on
you know what I mean well I can imagine
I wasn't here to hear it yeah Men In
Black showed up and told him to shut the
[ __ ] up yeah pretty much they told him
to stop well like I said they didn't
like threaten him or anything directly
but I guess they were like pretty so he
has every Legend that's what I'm saying
I'm surprised that he didn't have any of
those black-eyed kids you're right or I
almost said uh what's in a skinny man
like how about how about how how about
the wendigo when to go oh maybe you know
what um maybe the Brillo pad thing maybe
he maybe he met was wendigo I don't know
but I kind of think that it was probably
SAS box oh man that's what it's talking
about tall man should have showed it
slenderman slenderman slenderman yeah
that's like not that's not even an old
Legend though that's just a [ __ ] yeah
that's a creepypasta
but um but yeah
so he's just like really really pissed
at these [ __ ] aliens because these
aliens I mean these aliens are [ __ ]
right they're
well they are they just they've killed a
bunch of his animals like in a horrible
[ __ ] way he claims it [ __ ] dicks
yeah and also they're like [ __ ] with
him and they're like keep pushing his
wife out the [ __ ] house and you know
bruising them up and doing God knows
what they don't remember what it is like
I said they could be they could be
sticking you know vacuum cleaners up
there butts just like Christopher Walken
yeah and they don't even remember you
yeah it could be that could totally be
going on how dare you
yeah
um so basically okay and so this is a
crazy story too
so John's like he doesn't really know
what to do but apparently he's like well
something will happen like you know I'll
I'll figure this out somehow
so one particular day John is driving
down the road and he's behind this big
truck that had like all of this crap in
it like all this junk like somebody was
moving or if it was or Garbage or
something
um so he's sitting there going maybe I
should call the cops because it's like
you know all this [ __ ] is like gonna
fall out of that [ __ ] truck like if
they go over a bump or something like
that he's like I don't want it falling
on my car or nothing
so pretty much as soon as he thought
that the truck did hit a bump and a
bunch of the random [ __ ] like fell out
not onto his car but like onto the side
of the road
so John's like well [ __ ] man I'm gonna
go and pull through that stuff and see
if there's some good stuff in there
so he goes over there to look at what
had fallen out the truck because I guess
whoever was driving the truck was like
ah [ __ ] it and they just kept on going
but mixed into like it was mostly just a
bunch of crap like just junk and stuff
but he's like so I start digging through
it and I found a samurai sword
and he's like and it looked like a real
one like an old one you know what I mean
so he's like ah well okay I'm gonna keep
that [ __ ] thing so he put it in
the front seat of his car and uh you
know went back out
so uh basically he gets home and he
shows it to his wife and he's like hey
she's like where the [ __ ] you get that
he's like it fell off the back of a
truck which is what they used to say
about like hey where'd you get that VCR
fell off the back of a truck yeah
so um this is I should note that this
has actually been happening over quite a
long period of time like in case I
hadn't made that clear
um they moved into the into the place in
1996. and
um I think like by the time that he got
the samurai sword and all that this was
like 11 years later so they've lived
here for quite a long time with all of
these Shenanigans going on
so he puts the samurai sword he keeps
the samurai sword like next to his bed
just in case like the aliens think of
him trying anything like it's better
it's better than the baseball yeah [ __ ]
that AK I'm gonna put the sandwich did
he have an AK earlier he did I think he
had more than one he had like a bunch of
guys yeah with the AKA yeah he's yeah
well he shot at the mothership for sure
the mothership and it's like I don't
know if he hit it or nothing but like
the aliens were just kind of like hey
it's like chilling well this [ __ ] was
the size of a [ __ ] shopping center
how can you not hit it
maybe he's a terrible shot yeah maybe he
wasn't trying to hit it maybe he's I
don't know I don't know ridiculous
ridiculous ass [ __ ] story this is a
ridiculous story but it's super fun I
thought it was super fun
because I liked that he just like threw
everything in there you know what I mean
um so so yeah
what he decided to do
was that he said because all of this
crazy [ __ ] had been going on for such a
long time that he had pretty much
he had pretty much got to a point where
he knew when uh the Grays were gonna
show up or when some like weird [ __ ] was
gonna happen like he could feel it in
the air or whatever so he's like he
would get prepared for it
so one particular day this is you're
gonna you're gonna crack up okay you're
gonna love this okay um so one
particular day he's just hanging out in
his living room like watching TV and
working on some mechanical [ __ ] or
whatever like like a man do yeah man
gotta do this watching TV working
working on some machine parts or
something greasy hands probably getting
grease all over the carpet and his
wife's like what the [ __ ] are you doing
outside yeah what whatever they never do
though
I was building a motorcycle in the house
one time and [ __ ] opened it up [ __ ]
up remember that yeah I remember got the
oil went through the carpet but a quart
of it but it was brand new oil yeah
brand new it was clean oil yeah
well yeah but yeah it was hot outside
yeah so I'm not gonna build it out in
the garage [ __ ] that right now I'm gonna
have a heat stroke
so this is probably yeah that's probably
why yeah but yeah so he's uh so he's
watching TV to do with this stuff so um
so he's doing that and then he feels
that that little tingle that weird
Sensation that he feels that he's like
oh I know that the Grays are like up to
some [ __ ] you know what I mean yeah so
he's like but he's gonna pretend like
that he's that he doesn't see them or
that he doesn't notice because he wants
to see what's gonna happen right so he's
kind of like waiting like kind of
looking just low-key you know what I
mean and just waiting for them to like
start peeking around the walls and stuff
because remember I said they were doing
that they would like do that yeah
they're peeking yeah
aliens yeah
that's what they do Pookie does that too
yeah
get out of here
she had peeks around the side of the
wall or she peeks around the bedroom
door what are you guys doing yeah
she's like okay nevermind then she's
like runs back into the hallway I have a
six she'll creep up on you
she's watching
animals know what's up they do but yeah
it's funny but yeah it's Pookie Peaks
like that too well that's one of that's
what I was making me laugh about
thinking about all these little aliens
like peeking around like from behind the
couch and whatnot yeah because I was
like yeah like the kitty does that
um so yeah
so uh right so he's waiting for them to
to kind of pop out so then he sees one
like in the on the sun porch or whatever
just like it is peripheral vision and
he's just like pretending he doesn't see
it so he very calmly is like la la la
not seeing the alien do to do and he
goes into the bedroom and gets the
samurai sword and then kind of like
stashes it behind the door right then he
goes back to the TV and he's just like
pretended to watch TV again like blah
blah don't say the aliens that kind of
thing so then he sees two more little
aliens like pop up next to the first one
so then he gets up again
goes acting cash and then he goes in the
room and gets his samurai sword and then
comes out behind and he sees the three
little aliens like standing there and
the screen door is open and everything
like that because they were born at a
barn clearly
so at this point like he just takes a
deep breath and he charges at him right
with the samurai sword and swings it at
him yeah and he cut one of the aliens
heads off yeah
because he's trying to be a man trying
to be a man yeah see he [ __ ] up
anyways so the other is the [ __ ]
extraterrestrial did you come over here
you extra testicle
it was yeah yeah
so now he says we have an alien species
show up so you attack it with a sandwich
well they're [ __ ] I mean they've
been [ __ ] with this poor guy for like
many years at this point they're like
doing all kind of [ __ ] to him I'm not
buying into this [ __ ] story you don't
try to trap it and catch it because if
you can catch one you could sell them
and make all kinds of money off of it
yeah I mean I kind of feel like that's
probably why yeah I wouldn't try to kill
anything oh Pedro said nah come on
please
yeah yeah oh yeah he's [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah I cut off the alien's head yeah I'm
like who the [ __ ] are you come on now
just capture it it's worth [ __ ]
billions yeah I wonder could he really
have like a bear trap or something
because he said he used to see them all
around the around the ranch all the time
so it's like you know why'd you put some
like little alien chow or whatever
whatever it is that they would was like
a lure you know what I mean
alien Chow
I don't know where you'd get that
imagine if you you captured an alien
all right
and it's the real thing
you could probably hold that for ransom
you know what I mean [ __ ] get all
kinds of money off of it
well yeah especially if you should have
photographs or video of it so I got an
extraterrestrial bro got a hidden yeah I
got them chained up in my basement yeah
[ __ ] um you tell the CIA this [ __ ]
there that's it you know give me the
money and I'll take you to them and I
won't tell nobody yeah I want immunity
and everything okay man just yeah I mean
okay you could leverage the [ __ ] out of
that because if you go back and look at
the if you go and go and look at the
laws all the things about kidnapping and
murder and all it's about if it's a
human that only applies if it's a human
being it doesn't apply for to animals
and it wouldn't apply to
extraterrestrials
so they couldn't
criminally prosecute you for capturing
an alien
you can make all kinds of money
yeah you think unless they've added new
laws they say no you can't count you
can't do that to an alien and you can't
do this [ __ ] to Sasquatch
[Laughter]
States like uh no you can't kill
Sasquatch that's you know I think that
that might be that law might be on the
books in a few States in a few States
yeah you can't kill sassy I think it
might be there's no thermostat they're
like just in case though yeah they don't
know just in case I mean the situation
might arise and we don't want to have to
write a new law right you know what I
mean I get it uh El padrino said Mr Tom
since you have been to Brazil have you
heard of the 1980s alien capture
1980s alien capture yeah no I've never
heard of that either
there was a pretty famous Brazilian case
where some people out in the country
kept getting attacked by balls of light
and making Burns in them and uh some
[ __ ] happened there but
I don't know anything about and the Army
was involved
but I don't know if it's real or not you
know I wasn't there
and I'd have to research it more and
find out what the deal was
Brazil would be an easy place to hoax
stuff
James Knapp said can't remember if it's
Oregon or Washington but one of them has
a law that is illegal to kill a Bigfoot
yeah I thought it was one of those two
places I mean that's that's what I was
thinking of when I said that
so uh so yeah so he cuts off the alien
tag like you do so
he says that the other two whose heads
he didn't cut off like disappeared
immediately which of which they had been
doing like every time he shot at them
and whatnot think how ridiculous this is
well yeah
with a samurai sword where's the head
we'll see now okay I'm gonna get where's
the Habit again okay
so he said so the Dead one like was left
there now he was kind of excited about
this because he's like look um I've been
like shooting at these [ __ ] and
throwing things at them and stuff like
that and usually they just disappear but
now that I've cut its head off like it
actually stayed here all right so he
apparently
allegedly he wraps the the body up in
plastic right and put it in the freezer
like like you would do yeah now he's
like okay well now I I can prove it
because I've got the dead body
so he decides he's going to send like
tissue and blood samples to like a lap
for scientific testing
so he comes into uh contact with a
scientist and this is actually a real
guy I did look him up
um a scientist named WC Levin good okay
so um he's like a research physicist or
something like he's dead now but um but
yeah so he sent the samples of the
tissue like to the lab and gave leving
good like some others like samples as
well
now according to all the stories
leavengood said that the tissue in the
blood samples had uh very weird
properties that he had never seen before
and that didn't match any plant or
animal now I saw one thing that said
reportedly the blood was 100 hemoglobin
not sure if that's true or not but
that's what one of them said I don't
know if that's the case
um and also like uh They said that the
Le that the results that they got
seem to match like some other DNA or
some other blood samples and stuff that
they gotten from other like cattle
mutilation sites like around the
Southwest like I said I don't know if
that's true or not because it's not like
you can really find a lot of like
scientific papers about this it's
usually just other like Paranormal sites
like just repeating the same story so
it's like so yeah I'm just like I'm just
saying
so um
uh claims being parented by other
paranormal Investments right
investigators so
so that's what I mean so I'm always like
really really skeptical and like you try
to like look up the real people and it's
like really hard to find anything about
it yeah which sounds fishy because like
I said I now WC loving good is a real
guy on in Neil deGrasse Tyson and [ __ ]
see right right I will say the 11 good
is a real was a real guy he was a
research physicist and he had published
a handful of papers
that supposedly showed that plants from
his big thing was crop circles
um and that plants from crop circles and
to a lesser extent from cattle
mutilation sites how um displayed like
unique anatomical anatomical
characteristics
but I will note that critics of his work
um you know it's as far as I know his
papers are behind a paywall but he has
written like three or four of them
um but as far as I know the studies were
conducted uh they were not double blind
uh meaning that introduces the
possibility of bias obviously because
leavengood is not shy uh was not shy
about his belief that crop circles are
real and are caused by extraterrestrials
you know what I mean so it could just be
that
he really believed that so he was just
kind of like the data was kind of going
that way so 11 good actually circles are
not real no they're not they're they're
they're they're actually quite easy to
make they're easy to make they're quite
easy to make them and you don't you only
need a couple people aboard a rope and
it's like you don't even need that long
they there's videos all over the place
of people they're making those and
they're just they're not they're they're
very cool but they're art they're not
they're not they're not yeah that's true
no not not at all but um but yeah so
love it good he was a roll guy uh he was
a research physicist as I said uh he
worked at a place called The Science and
Technology The Institute of Science and
Technology in the Department of Natural
Resources at the University of Michigan
he worked there from for like nine years
from 1961 through 1970 and then he
worked at a place called uh he was the
director of biophysical research
uh in the private sector now one thing
that I did see come up a lot was that
there were some see this is what I mean
where where a lot of this stuff gets
repeated across paranormal sites but
then when you check into it it's not
true
um one of the stories that went around
about leavengood was that he died in a
lab explosion or that his lab burned
down and that like all the evidence that
he was keeping there was gone that
apparently does not seem to be the case
he did die in 2013 I found his obituary
um it doesn't mention that he died like
that it does mention that he was 88
years old and there was a post
underneath like one announcement of his
death that said that was a friend of his
and said that he just died in a hospice
in Jackson Michigan like it wasn't a lab
explosion or nothing 88 is a full life I
mean it's your time yeah
that's what I'm saying so I don't think
there was anything weird I don't think
there was anything particularly weird
about the lab
I mean unless it's all been covered up
or something but I couldn't find
anything like that and from what I could
determine like his death was looked
normal like he just died at a hospice
when he was 88.
so I don't know about like all the
laughing or anything like that
um so uh so at this point so I don't
know it's you know the the samples it's
like yeah they're unusual but there
didn't really seem to be anything and
like I said if you've got a whole alien
head
yeah where's the head that's what I'm
saying it's like I thought he had a
whole head and you know he has left the
body behind I'm just I'm just taking
well no he had the head and the body
yeah I guess like he wrapped him in
plastic but like yeah I mean if you had
an alien head you'd think he would take
the whole head not just like tissue
samples it's like hey I've got a whole
[ __ ] head he had the whole head and
the whole body you'd be a billionaire
that's what I'm saying because you now
have the fight of the century
you can prove it yeah and that you have
custody of it
no I have to believe in this [ __ ] man
what are you talking about yes yeah
everybody'd be all over that yeah you
think they'd cut you a check to [ __ ]
surrender that thing to keep your mouth
shut so it would happen
yeah that's why I'm suspicious you're
right I mean I'm suspicious because his
story was that he and
um he also like later on after all of
this stuff happened he also went to one
of those hypnotherapists you know that
that alien abductees go to often that I
hate to say but they do kind of like
plant memories that people said because
that's really not that hard to do
so uh so if you went to one of those
and through these sessions uh he learned
or you know or or it was put in his head
that he had been abducted by the Grays
18 separate times and that he had no
conscious memory of this
um but those but you know he he'd been
waking up and having all these wounds
and stuff and those were the times that
he'd been abducted and his wife had also
been abducted yada yada
um and like I said they they hinted
around that maybe there'd been like some
sexual abuse going on with aliens too
but they didn't really want to talk
about that because you know aliens come
here just to get laid well yeah they do
like I said we'll just they come here to
stick pretty much yeah and you look at
the people you're like man what would
they want with you man you're [ __ ]
ugly man well maybe they have different
beauty standards on whatever Planet they
come from yeah you know you don't know
you're just you're you're being very
very human human Cedric right yeah like
aliens might have a totally different
set of like you gotta be in middle age
gotta be a middle-aged ugly [ __ ]
to get [ __ ] butt hurt by the aliens
that's what I mean they they like like
um big old chubby uh you know balding
dudes yeah Jethro from jet yeah from
Kansas or yeah not flexible [ __ ]
I can't even put the ankles behind the
ears that's what they're interested in I
ain't buying it El potrita says 18 times
you've been violated by an alien your
booty must be the Ark of the universe
yeah yeah coming across [ __ ] Galaxy
to come get some of that ass off I mean
that does make you feel special I guess
it's like man
the aliens came all this way just to
stick a vacuum cleaner in my butt how
dare you
no [ __ ] I just they would now they
might come all that way for Christopher
Walken yeah for walking
I could see that yeah yeah I could see
that
he's in my ass five years yeah he should
have oh my God how funny would it have
been if if
um Quentin Tarantino had told
Christopher Walken it's like oh can we
tie this in with communion tell them
that the aliens use the vacuum cleaner
to put the watch in your butt yeah right
yeah it's like that would have been
hysterical because it's like that well
not that many people would get that
reference so it's like no just now I
kind of want to match up it's funny how
foreign
just joining us and they don't they're
not new to this show or they're new to
this show we're not making fun of these
UFO cases because it's UFO case there
are some good ones I'm like yeah I think
that [ __ ] was extraterrestrial all right
it's just some of this stuff is just
[ __ ] terrible you know what I mean
I mean like I said you can see the
little outlandish and you can see the
American cultural fingerprint and it on
a lot of these cases and it's always
a fingerprint of the time okay yeah
back in the 50s it was you know [ __ ]
old Elmer in his [ __ ] coveralls
saying that he [ __ ] 300 pounds
all right going oh yeah the aliens came
down and it was a beautiful alien woman
and her and I had a child together you
know they're like man get the [ __ ] out
of it
women here don't watch you okay
they're gonna come across the [ __ ]
you know
solar systems to [ __ ] come get some
of Elmer's [ __ ]
[Music]
that's not gonna happen bro
it's gonna happen but that's just
in yeah in every decade you can see how
it's very much a uh an artifact of its
time
aliens would be unrecognizable to a
human being if you ask me I I think I
think really what what you have correct
the I think the closest thing to
probably what will be reality is what
you saw in 2001 the monolith shows up
and you can't understand it
you know what I mean alien technology
would be incomprehensible to you
in the same way
that a [ __ ] monkey can never really
understand what a jet is what a jet
fighter is
you know what I mean a monkey might see
a jet fighter but it would never really
understand what that was or how to make
that or how to sh or how to fly that or
what it was actually for and then the
industries you need to make that
it would be like that it would be like
magic to us it would just be like the
monolith out of 2001.
where you're not really sure is that the
alien is that it's technology what is it
you know it did this thing it it could
create [ __ ] stars [ __ ] you know how
does this work it's like magic
and that's really what it is it makes
sense to the aliens it makes sense to
the aliens because their technology is
so Advanced it's beyond your ability to
comprehend because you're just a bug
compared to them
and from your point of view it is Magic
you know not from their point of view
but from your you just don't have your
brain isn't is can't compute it you know
that's what it would be you're talking
about a superior species
but humans are arrogant they think that
the whole man and nothing's going to be
smarter than me these things are so
smart you're an inferior little bug
compared to them
or a monkey
if it could get here across the [ __ ]
vastness of [ __ ] space
okay it's Superior to you
it's intelligence it's [ __ ] fantastic
you know you're nothing compared to it I
mean it's not interested in you probably
see that's why anytime like I I'm not
averse to it's like oh you know they saw
like lights in the sky and I thought
that was the UFO like that's not that
weird but the second you start talking
about oh they abducted me and stuck
things in my butt and like did this and
that and the other thing I'm just kind
of like
I just kind of feel like that's maybe
your fetish or you just had a nightmare
or something like that because why the
[ __ ] would an alien do that think about
this let's be rational
you're driving your car
down the [ __ ] freeway trying to get
to the club
and you pass a stork on the side of the
road are you gonna stop and [ __ ]
contact the stork and try to tell the
story hey I'm a person I'm going to the
club I'm here to make first contact with
your people no we just [ __ ] keep
driving all right and that's probably
what the aliens just see you and go yeah
one of those those are everywhere
you know there's lots of those
things on planets yeah [ __ ] them we got
[ __ ] we got to do hey get out of the
road little dude yeah yeah
like we do with a turtle yeah
he would just be another life form on
planets and they see that all the time
and they wouldn't care
they wouldn't care about you until
you're like them which that's millions
of years away from us in terms of
evolution
probably machine intelligence not even
biological
logical life like us there's a lot of
limitations you get old and you die so
you don't live long
yeah that sucks if you were a machine
intelligence you could be immortal
and constantly be upgrading your body if
you needed a body you might exist inside
a metaverse
I'm I'm pushing for that I can't wait
till I can download my Consciousness
into like some other [ __ ] into like
avatars and stuff if it actually works I
mean you know I'm just saying like a
trial first well yeah to see if it
actually works and then go okay yeah
we'll try it out if it's if it's cool
then yeah I would I would totally do
that yeah and I don't want to know who
who's running that [ __ ] what are the
rules like in there you know what I mean
how free are you and like yeah okay I'm
70 something there's no I don't have
many years left on that body life in
here is better than the life out there
so yeah I'm just gonna go ahead I'm
gonna die in a couple years anyway I'll
just staying here
but I'd have to have a trial first
you know of what the what a metaverse
would be like
yeah you try it out and it would be at
the end of life
you know not the beginning I don't
believe that you know if you want to do
that with your young you want to be like
a dab
like a a chrysalis like like an egg
turning it into a worm turned into a
chrysalis and into a butterfly you know
what I mean stages in your development
you'd be your person you're biological
you start to get old and instead of
dying and Vanishing you can preserve
yourself inside a metaverse and live in
that
for a few centuries you know and do
stuff from the metaverse in the real
world you know
American Military 100 said since you
guys are pushing for more subscribers
and patrons I would recommend doing a
[ __ ] that's topical I.E the Idaho
student murders yeah I've been thinking
about doing a show about that I actually
put it in the poll like to do a show
about it but it didn't win like this
actually won but I don't know maybe we
would come on like one time because I
was reading about it earlier today what
does it have to do with uh um what does
that have to do with the patrons well
meaning you're going to get more like uh
views because a lot because that is a
topic that's trending oh it's like in
True Crime I didn't know because it's
something that just happened okay all
right I didn't know about that right
right yeah we I've always encouraged Jan
to maybe we should do more current
topics
but a lot of the current topics are kind
of depressing or incomplete like it was
a new case if they catch a serial killer
we hit that right we jump right on that
I probably should I kind of feel like
well because I have so many things going
on it's like hard for me to keep track
of stuff I have been trying to
think about
um you know particularly since we do
like True Crime stuff and we do horror
stuff I was like maybe I should like try
to keep up with stuff that's going on
more like I like doing the stuff that we
do that's like old and not have to worry
about it but I do kind of feel like we
might get more subscribers and stuff
like that if we
do you know if we did more and we'd only
have to do it like maybe once or twice a
week or something like that when
something hits the big time we just you
gotta jump on it to be topical yeah and
that doesn't happen that often actually
yeah a couple times a year I mean I have
been trying to keep up because I do my
crime and Memorial site and it's like so
I do try to keep up with particularly
old cases that I wrote about before that
have been solved because some of them
have like they've identified some people
or they figure out who did stuff so I
have been trying to keep on top of that
but you know what I mean it's it's a lot
to keep it's a good suggestion though
yeah yeah and like I said I have been
thinking about doing that
El padrino said I can honestly see
Robert Stack reporting on anal rape by
an alien on an episode of Unsolved
Mysteries I would laugh my ass off just
by hearing his voice stack hated those
UFO uh um episodes
well he got he got into the show for
doing the True Crime stuff like finding
people that got murdered and like
missing people and stuff like that I
kind of feel like whenever they wanted
him to do the Paranormal stuff he was
like man do I have to I think there were
a few of them I think he thought there
was something too but um
I think he thought there was something
to the Belgian wave
because so many French John Marie saw it
okay and I think there was something to
the Belgian wave uh that was a good case
did we do a show about that nah I don't
think we did we need to do one about the
Belgium I could have sworn we did but
maybe I mean we've done so many shows
yeah just do that I'll write it down you
guys want one on the Belgian wave the
bell I mean I'll put it in the I'll put
it in a lot of cool [ __ ] happened during
that one that was over a period of about
a year
um I mean that sounds familiar so I feel
like yeah the Belgian Air Force picked
up stuff the Belgian cops saw a bunch of
stuff just strange triangular craft
the little balls would come out and
measure things and look at the water and
then move on and it was just and then
they left but a lot of cops a lot of
a lot of a lot of Belgian cops suck
the French cops and [ __ ]
all right so let's let's get back to
this because we don't have that much
more to go on this well then we can talk
about some other stuff okay but um but
yeah so over the following several years
John claimed to have killed
19 aliens I guess with the samurai sword
um so at this point I guess he here's
the thing like he said that he'd started
he'd stopped posting stuff online
because the Men in Black came and like
told him not to but I guess he started
doing it again because in 2011
um you know the the story had kind of
gone I don't know if I'd call it viral
but like people started hearing about it
so he started getting like calls and
messages and stuff from other people
that had had similar experiences or were
psychics or whatever uh he ended up
getting a phone call from a woman named
Brandy Howe who is a doctor of divinity
uh she actually was on the ghost hunt
the Ghost Adventures uh episode that
they did about this so she's on there
so she actually got hired
to help him out
by this other woman named Cynthia
Crawford
now Cynthia Crawford uh listen to this
[ __ ] this is this is a piece of work
because I looked her up to now she had
heard about what the weird [ __ ] that was
going on at the ranch
now Cynthia who I think is still around
she's an artist
but she her claims are
that she was born a fraternal twin
but that she had a completely different
blood type and tissue type than her twin
sister
um how is that possible well wait I'm
getting into it okay
um she also said
that her dad was kind of like a high
mukety muck in the OSS which was PRI the
progenitor to the CIA yeah World War II
the long-time Library yeah so I mean
yeah she's born she was born in the 50s
or something okay so um her dad said
that he was uh he knew about all these
like secret Technologies alien treaties
all this kind of stuff he was all in
Project paper clip which was the whole
thing with the Nazi with the Nazis in
the World War II and stuff like that
yeah bringing Nazi scientists in right
into the fold yeah so so remember when I
said that she was born and like she had
like a totally different blood type than
her sister she also claimed that she was
born without an amniotic sac
and that
when she was older her dad told her yeah
that he had been approached by agents
OSS agents to participate in a secret
government project to make a human alien
hybrid
and that that's what she was she had
been grown in a petri dish
and then put in the in the womb
no well obviously okay but I'm just
saying that's what her story is okay so
apparently she said that she'd been
taken to like all these underground
military medical facilities like when
she was a kid and all this other kind of
stuff so she was saying back in the 50s
she was a product of in vitro
fertilization and that she was
hybridization of human and alien DNA
yeah and she was put into a damn woman
no I'm already no no
yeah well I told you no I told you
you're gonna love this yeah okay all
right so um so yeah
so that was her story and she's sticking
to it okay uh so
like I said she's an artist and uh she
talks a lot about kind of star beings
and all that kind of stuff
so you know
so she uh heard about Star Trek man
we're humans and Falcons can crossbreed
and [ __ ] crossbreed no man [ __ ]
alien
an alien species it's genetic code if
even if it had DNA it probably would
have something like DNA you just would
not be able to crossbreed you can't even
cross-breed with other species of
animals that are from the Earth
what makes you think you can cross breed
with it with it with it within it with
it
with an alien yeah that's what I mean
it's like you can't go you can't go [ __ ]
a cow and have like a little cow man
hybrid the closest thing to it that we
know of the closest thing to a human
being is a chimpanzee and you can't
cross breed with them
yeah you know it's just not gonna happen
it didn't work out now it could happen
between a horse and a donkey you'll get
a mule but it'll be sterile yeah
but no you're not gonna be able to
[ __ ]
I mean it really doesn't take that much
distance between two species before they
became and a lot of times they can
produce Offspring but The Offspring are
sterile yeah yeah like and then that's
kind of like along the way of just
becoming too certain big cats can cross
breed lion and tiger or a lion and a
tiger can make a liger yeah but then the
liger sterile yeah so you know but
you're talking about an intelligent
being from another planet you won't be
able to cross breed with that no [ __ ] no
and have a totally different genome well
the evolution on that planet would have
been completely different different than
ours it's DNA may not even [ __ ] have
the same chemicals that are proteins
involved you know I mean it's just no
well yeah because it might like I said
it might be completely different from
the ground up
from the ground up yeah it's D it's DNA
Helix might not be based on four things
it might be based on six yeah you know
you don't know
well aren't well I think even [ __ ]
Star Trek went into that because of some
of the like alien species were like
silicone based instead of like carbon
based and stuff like that which is I
looked into that I don't think it's
possible well no but I mean I'm just
saying that I mean that's a good like
hypothetical because it doesn't life
doesn't necessarily have to be the way
it is here lots of different ways that
it could have carbon and water are the
way to go uh pretty much that that's it
that's how you make a
there might be very primitive life on
some places like [ __ ] Europa here you
know the moon around Jupiter you know
you might have some it's very low
temperature but it would never become an
advanced form of life
Europa might have something underneath
uh underneath the ocean but it wouldn't
be more complicated than a fish I don't
think uh but that'd be really stretching
it
it does have liquid water though so in
it you know but which is yeah it does
have liquid water it could it could be
all right but I'm not sure there's
enough energy there in terms of heat you
know
and then you go to place like Titan
where it's [ __ ] very cold where you
know [ __ ] what is it gases or liquid
there you know
and I don't know how if there was
anything on planets that cold the
metabolisms of those creatures would be
so slow they'd be happening at another
time scale where they lived for
centuries
but they're tiny
they're tiny organisms you know like a
micro you know they're what they call it
microbiology
I don't think it'd be anything big
it's just too much Star Trek you know
what I mean [ __ ] yeah I'm just saying
that it's like you know just from yeah I
don't like to burst anyone's bubble but
yeah chances are
when you deal with extraterrestrial life
forms
they're going to be coming from planets
like Earth
they're probably gonna but they're gonna
be very different very different
their DNA they'll have something like
DNA but it will be totally different
because they've clawed their way up
through a totally different process of
selection and different ancestry and
well and the thing that people forget
too is that um you know the process of
evolution on Earth is a lot of it is um
based on just contingencies which were
based on just random [ __ ] that look at
the random [ __ ] that happened yeah you
know look at what happened to the
dinosaurs that's kind of like the most
obvious example with the [ __ ] Comet
or whatever but had that not happened
then like we would not be here because
it took them out of the large Predators
like out of the niche I'm convinced that
in the universe and in our galaxy life
is common
most of it I'm sure it probably most of
it's going to be microbes
you're going to see large creatures
though and it's going to be mostly on
planets that are kind of like Earth
uh you would be able to cross breed them
with them though and it's going to be
mostly animals and plants things like
that yeah what's your other two yeah
like you mentioned we can't even
crossbreed with animal other animals on
this planet which are related to us yeah
demonstrably right so there's no way
people crossed with them yeah and um
other planets are going to be things
like plants and things like animals and
things that are kind of a cross between
the two being the planet animal it could
be a lot of aquatic based type life
forms because you know
there's gonna be a lot of water on
Earth-like planets on other in other
places
but technological civilization is going
to be a very rare real rare for any
given time there's probably a lot of
them in the past and there'll be a lot
of them in the future but time is
another thing you got to look at
uh right now
there's probably not too in our galaxy
or probably not too many technological
civilizations
uh and then the other ones that exist
are probably centuries behind us and
other ones are maybe millions of years
ahead of us
there's probably nothing in this galaxy
that's the same as us or at the same
level
they're either gonna be ahead or behind
the chances of there being one just like
us
in this galaxy zero
thank you mango
Kraken show and subject thank you
Android cold sends their love okay okay
Tom Sykes says John Edmonds has photos
of the Grays but they look sketchy yeah
yeah I mean this whole story is pretty
sketchy he's making this up
please well he's dead but um he just
died last year I think he made this up
but um but yeah so who are we talking
about okay so Cynthia Crawford she was
the one that said that she was uh you
know for a product of alien DNA
she was the one that hired this other
woman Brandy Howe now Brandi Howe goes
to and like I said Brandy Howe as far as
I know was on the Ghost Adventures
episode because I saw clips of that too
and I saw like pictures of her
but she goes out to The Ranch to help
John Edmonds out
Brandy says to John
um well
so like I don't know what the [ __ ]
deal is but I guess most aliens are nice
but she's like um the aliens that you
have are having a problem with are
Renegade aliens
Brandy says that she's been abducted
lots of times since she was four years
old
and um also has psychic powers because
of course she does yeah so she um she
says the Cynthia woman the alien hybrid
woman
she hired Brandy to investigate the
ranch
and Brandy said that she was told
to bring two aliens from the serious
constellation with her to investigate
whatever was going on with this for
whatever reason
so John and Brandi are talking for a bit
um so Brandi comes to this Ranch like to
do the investigation and she did indeed
have two dudes with her
and she claimed that these two dudes
were from
serious
um and she called them both Jay
and I was like
all right so
in the Men In Black movie
the one with Tommy Lee Jones and Will
Smith in it weren't their names J and K
I kind of feel like I mean it's been a
long time since I've seen it but
somebody help me out here I was like so
are we all are we getting ideas from the
movies now because I just feel like
everything in here is like from a movie
you know what I mean so yeah so both of
these guys that she brought who just
apparently just looked like regular guys
but she said that they were aliens and
that they were from
that they were from the serious uh
constellation or whatever the star or
whatever and she called them both Jay
maybe that was both their names I mean
it's not that uncommon a name I'm just
saying
so um she says that the reason that she
brought these two guys with her
that is because the syrians are Like a
Warrior Race of aliens so I guess I
don't know like the Klingons but maybe
not evil I don't really know
and so they're basically like if you
have like some [ __ ] that needs to get
done like a problem that needs to get
cleaned up or something those are the
[ __ ] you call like that's those
are the experts in that situation you
know what I mean so uh so that's why she
brought these two guys the two G's she
brought that with her this story is just
getting so [ __ ] it's just getting
crazier I was reading the whole thing
and I'm just like you have got to be
kidding me like the okay sounds like
some Whitney Street or [ __ ] that's
what I mean this is like like I said if
you're okay if you're gonna like write
some paranormal stuff
um and you're gonna make it up and you
want people to think it's a true story
like just to make some money or whatever
um I would advise you to kind of keep it
low-key just keep a low-key don't go
this crazy with it because like most of
most people are not gonna believe you I
think it's more believable if you keep
it
a little bit not as outlandish as this
now hold on wait a minute
El padrino says she's a Scientologist
who whoever it is we're talking about
she said she's a Scientologist
oh I wonder if that's um I don't know
she's talking about this brand this
Brandy woman maybe that that makes sense
they're all into aliens and stuff yeah
so Brandi brings Brandy brings the two
guys from Sirius uh both of whom's name
is Jay
uh you know because they're Warrior
aliens yeah so she brings yeah because
of course of course so yeah well
everybody so
[Laughter]
so she brings him to the ranch to deal
with these Renegade aliens Renegade
alien issue it's been going on Renegade
let's start this way he's like [ __ ]
with the animals and whatnot
so they just come there and uh
apparently Brandi says she feels like a
disturbance in the force or whatever
there's kind of some kind of like Port
some portals or some [ __ ] I think they
say they said that um John had seen like
portals around the place too I think
I've neglected to mention that okay
but um yeah I think I saw that someplace
all right so she's like okay well
there's portals over here so that's why
you're getting so many Grays it's kind
of like a hangout place like it's like a
bus station it's like it's like it's
like the Greyhound bus station but with
grays for aliens see how I did that all
right so uh so Brandy and the two aliens
the good aliens they do a cleansing
prayer which is like I said it's just
like a haunting they didn't like have
any cool [ __ ] to do I don't know so they
just do the same [ __ ] you do to like to
get rid of ghosts I guess so they do it
all around the property
and then
um Brandy's tells John oh hey I created
another portal in your house
and some of the aliens want to talk to
you
um because the portal that I created
like allows the aliens to talk to you
right
so they go in the house and there's kind
of like
a a hologram type thing that looks like
a globe or some [ __ ] like in the house
and you're gonna love this
and so three
things like three aliens come out the
the hologram
and they're carrying swords and they
have breastplates on like medieval style
these are medieval aliens that sounds
like something modern damn revelation
yeah that's what I'm saying well maybe
that's maybe that's why on Ghost
Adventures they thought this was like
some demonic chicken right because it's
like yeah it does actually sound
everything in this sounds like it came
from someplace else yeah like a movie or
a book or something it's all rebooted
yeah they're just like they just yeah we
got [ __ ] from everywhere
um so apparently Brandi said she
couldn't see them but John could see
them you know what I mean yeah like uh
John's wife Joyce she said she saw like
the globe thing and the weird light in
the room she didn't see the aliens
either John was only with all the aliens
but everybody else said that they saw
like the light or the globe of the
Hologram or whatever the [ __ ]
so um apparently John and the aliens
have some kind of conversation I don't
really know what they were talking about
and then Brandy uh goes out on the
property again and said that she went
and telepathically talked to the animals
about what was going on
and Brandy said that the aliens were
allowed to kill the animals but weren't
allowed to kill the people
because
whoever was letting the aliens kill the
animals said oh we can kill the animals
and no one will do anything but if you
kill a human then
um a superior would come and like punish
you
right yeah so I guess so they're just
kept [ __ ] with the people but they
didn't kill them all right but they're
just like well the aliens want you out
of here because like this is their area
because all the portals are here
so they've been trying to get rid of you
and they're mad because you didn't leave
it's a ridiculous [ __ ] that's what I'm
telling you yeah I'm telling you I'm
cute I'm doing a good job I'm keeping a
straight face yeah look at this [ __ ] I'm
so you know what I mean I I'm if I do
say so myself yeah so she's out there
like after she's done telepathically
talking to the animals which like I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna make too much
fun of that but you know what I mean
because I talked to the catalog she
telepathically talking to the foot
that's what I mean I talked to poop I
don't know if I'd say telepath you don't
have to tell a fact that you've talked
to poop because she just looks at you
you know exactly what she's thinking
well yeah well that's what I mean it's
kind of like telepathic yeah and a lot
of times sometimes I'll think and I'll
think I wonder where Pokey is and then
she'll and then she'll come and peek in
the door like what were you like did you
call me yeah yeah so she does that dive
on her back and put her feet up in here
El padrino said no I bet she sounds like
a Scientologist oh okay oh okay okay I
mean you know it's hard to tell these
days
so uh so yeah so they're doing all these
blessings around the property and
whatnot
um and she said that what she was doing
was that she was trying to like make it
so that was harder for the for the
aliens to like come through so she's
like out of closing up the portals or
blocking the portals or I don't know
what
so um so while they're all looking like
out on the property uh they saw a bunch
of alien spacecraft like appear in the
sky like over the property and they said
one of them was like like a really
really big like as big as like several
city blocks they said
um and then John said that he saw like
the mothership it looked like just this
whole big [ __ ] City like floating in
the sky
and then Brandy starts talking like
starts saying this weird [ __ ] like in
some weird unknown language right
um and then she said that she she later
said that she was talking to the grays
and she's like you need to go with these
ships and like get the [ __ ] out of here
is basically what she was telling them
and she also said that uh the ships had
come there I think she said that the
ships had come there and that
whoever was in the ships was like mad at
the Grays that were [ __ ] around on
the earth and the reason that they came
there and like like uncloaked or
whatever was just kind of like man you
[ __ ] better get back in this
[ __ ] ship because you're you're you
know [ __ ] up
so
Brandi also said
there are three ships
with about 20 Grays per ship living on
this property so 60 Grays live on this
property
um that's what she said
so
then they do this little ritual where
her and the two aliens that she brought
with her the syrians
um they kind of like did this weird
thing with the swords and like touched
the tips together and like purple
lightning went everywhere and all this
other kind of stuff this is like right
out of Revelations that's what I mean
this is like this is the story so John's
like watching all this go on and then
he's just kind of like holy [ __ ]
um and apparently like the lightning
struck around and there was like you
know it was burned there and everything
like that
so after that the two jays who are from
Sirius they like went they left and then
Brandi likes goes to leave and then
she's like I don't think the Grays will
be a problem anymore she says because
she she took care of that [ __ ] and then
she left
so apparently like John and Brandy were
like talking over the next few weeks
Brandi said she had some memory loss
about it one of the aliens that she had
brought with her uh apparently went
crazy and was put into mental
institution
um and I think what they said later on
was that the two guys that were
supposedly from Sirius they were what
they call walk-ins meaning not like a
walk-in clinic but like um I guess alien
Souls like walk in your body and like
kick your soul out like a willingly or
something I don't really know what the I
don't know how that works but yeah so
that's apparently what those two guys
were like they were humans but aliens
had come down and be like hey are you
using this body thanks I was like I'm
gonna I'm gonna use this so there was
that
so apparently uh John claimed that after
this whole incident that he was pretty
much in contact with nice aliens uh for
pretty much every day like he he talked
to the aliens all the time
um for just years ever since he you know
talked to the to the syrians the Jays
so he said that he asked them like a
whole bunch of questions about like life
and philosophy and the universe and all
that other kind of stuff but he'd only
ever give them like they'd only ever
give him like really uh cryptic sort of
uh answers so of course
now 2000 it was around 2016 or 2017. I
feel like that's when kind of this story
went kind of wider because he was trying
to sell the ranch around this time
and I believe
please correct me if I'm wrong but I
believe he was trying to sell it for
five million dollars which
I don't really know how because I mean
it's 10 acres
and the house is nice but I don't really
know if it's worth five million dollars
so I don't really know if this is a
story he came up with just to like
sell it for five million dollars or I'm
not really sure but so he was trying to
sell it
but
um apparently it didn't sell
so I guess they left it on the market
for several years and you know they
never sold it and I don't know like if
they went bankrupt or something like
that but um John Edmonds did die like in
February of 2022 like I think Joyce is
still alive but I'm not entirely sure if
she still lives there
um and I'm not sure if they're in some
if she's in some kind of financial
trouble because I don't really know
because I kind of I was listening to One
podcast that said oh well he probably
just made up the whole story like to
sell the [ __ ] for five million dollars
but I don't know if it ever sold because
I saw some other stuff that said oh yeah
they did sell it for five million
dollars but I saw another one that said
it never sold you know what I mean that
she still lived there so I don't really
know
so um apparently I've heard too that it
was in foreclosure so I don't know if
they're gonna do like a bank auction or
something like that so I don't really
know
I don't really know what the what the
truth of the matter is you know so I'm
just saying
I don't I don't know if this was all it
sounds like a hoax I mean this sounds
like the craziest one of the craziest
[ __ ] things one of the craziest
[ __ ] things that I've ever heard and
I'm really proud of myself for keeping a
[ __ ] straight face like through that
what's that whole story because when I
was reading it
um I mean even from the beginning like
with the stuff about that it was creepy
like the [ __ ] about the pool and
everything like the furniture in the
pool and all that kind of stuff I'm like
yeah that's pretty creepy but it's like
as as it went on I was just kind of like
oh this is what okay we're going here
now and it's like no now there's Men In
Black and oh now there's the Sasquatch
and now there's this and that and the
other thing and I'm just kind of el
padre said Bob Lazar bought it yeah
[ __ ] it look man
at least Lazar had some plausible
deniability in a certain way where maybe
I don't know if that's a good term but
Bob Lazar never gave you enough to where
you could disprove what he's saying over
time yeah you're a bullshitter but
[ __ ] in the beginning you you could
actually
pre-internet you could kind of buy that
maybe bizarre knew something
I still like Lazar though he but he's an
act we did a show about him too yeah
he's a good act
I kind of feel like yeah and especially
nowadays when it's so easy to check on
stuff yeah I kind of feel like if you're
gonna
if you're gonna make up something like
this like you said keep the details kind
of big right so that people can't check
on stuff and like I said my my advice
would be don't
um don't make it this outlandish
because you know what I mean now some
people are gonna believe it sure but
it's like
cynical [ __ ] like me man I'm
just like
I
I seriously I don't know if there's like
a single detail about this that I could
totally Buy
I just don't
the only thing I could believe I could
believe that you moved into the house
and some [ __ ] like didn't move
their furniture
I believe that
could happen but it's like after that
I'm just like no no I don't believe any
of that stuff nope
[Laughter]
Oracle says if the details are vague
sometimes people will fill the story
gaps for you exactly exactly ideally
that's what you want to happen you want
people to take your story and kind of
like run with it and come up with
theories but with you just being like
real kind of cagey about it's like well
I don't know man it's like you know
there could have been this could have
been don't be too specific because
people can check that [ __ ] we're looking
back on it in the 90s when a lot of this
[ __ ] came out well on this new UFO stuff
was coming out back in the back in the
[ __ ]
um
back in the days of the alien autopsy
and all that it wasn't what they were
saying what they were saying was pretty
in each case it was actually very vague
uh what I was actually getting [ __ ]
when I looked back on it was my
imagination filling in the damn gaps
you know my imagination run a wild with
me about
you know well if they said this does
this mean this and you know they were
just they were just good
less is better
when it comes to these kind of cases
the more you know
the less you believe
what was the name of that [ __ ]
um
what's the name of that television
series that was out at that time The
X-Files
the UFO [ __ ] the UFO [ __ ] craze
was [ __ ] high during the during the
90s when the X-Files was out
and um
it was just something about it where
they weren't giving you enough they
weren't really giving you very much
information so you like you said you
feel you feel your imagination filled in
the blanks and it was your imagination
that was really doing all the work
you know
and that's really why our Bell was
[ __ ] great Art Bell was doing the
same thing
he would have you know you'd [ __ ]
tune in to his [ __ ] radio station the
radio his radio program
it was hard it was hard to access it
everywhere in the in the depending on
where you were you know in the United
States at the time
so it's kind of like it was uh it was
like underground kind of special and
then you'd hear [ __ ] art and the less
art gave you
the [ __ ] more impressive than it was
what you doing Jeff
please what door that closet door oh it
was open he left it open
so I'm getting yelled at free to leave
in the closet door well because she's
afraid Pookie's gonna go in and hang
herself she did one time yeah that's
what I mean that's why I don't open it
anymore because she goes in there and
climbs and she plays some commercials or
something well it's almost
okay okay which one
we'll see if you find where Pookie is I
didn't see her in the closet but she
likes to go in that closet and I don't
like her to go in there because one time
she went in there and
um she got she was trying to like jump
through something and she got caught
like on a um I don't know what it was
like a bra strap or
a coat hanger or something like that and
she was like hanging like that and I had
to you know I heard her so I found her
but
she likes to go in there and I don't
like her to go in there so Tom was going
in there and getting the wig and he just
left it open so it's been open for like
a really long time hopefully she's not
in there
yeah
I didn't see her in there but she just
wants to go in there all the time and I
keep trying to tell her it's like you
don't need to go in there
I mean I'll let her go in there if I
watch her you know what I mean but I'm
not gonna let her just go in there so I
don't know I didn't see her in there
maybe she went somewhere else I don't
know where she went but yeah
um hello Veterinary said you guys should
do a video live at the gates of area 51.
yeah we've been talking about
um
I don't know like eventually when we
have some money or something like that I
would actually like to do a few shows
like in the field like I'd actually like
to go we'd have to probably start
um you know close by because I was like
I wouldn't mind doing a show from like
Saint Augustine or something like that
because there's a lot of really cool
[ __ ] there and it's like you know really
cool visually
and that's not that far from here it's
only like an hour drive
so you know or maybe we could do like
Cassadaga or we could there's all kind
of like haunted [ __ ] around Florida we
could do that but
I don't know we'll have to see one of
the things that we're thinking about
doing this year if we have money is
doing [ __ ] from the field did you see
her anywhere nice here hmm I don't think
she's in the closet I just like I dug
around in there and I didn't see are you
hungry yeah I'm starving I'll make
something to eat all right well I guess
we're almost at three hours so might as
well okay might as well close it down I
guess but I would say I was saying that
one of the things we were thinking about
doing this year if we had the money was
doing shows from
locations
you know yeah
yeah
okay
yeah yeah all right all right so I guess
we're gonna wrap it up for this evening
so we'll be back Friday night for the
Side Tracks show so thanks everybody for
dropping this is actually a fun show
because the topic was so was so out
there so you know those are usually fun
to do so uh so yeah so we'll see you
guys again Friday night thanks for
dropping by and hanging out with us
thanks for your super chats and we'll
see you guys on Friday good night